une production du studio sf bio venus au
sans filtre présenter parquet semi le
podcast où on parle de convaincre nos
invités des verges avec moins d'une
plante qui suit vous le savez en oeuvre
par les plantes des arbres à chaque fois
que vous achetez un cas il est là depuis
2001 y ont planté cent mille arbres
c'est énorme puis contemplant t 60
milles jusqu'à la fin de l'année
de plus donc c'est à chaque fois que
vous commandez en fait un ketch et keith
null participer à cette initiative le
vous encourager aussi une entreprise
québécoise en beauce et vous entre vous
aurez vous encourager aussi des amis en
fait que profitez-en aller voir son
encadrement pour vous qui le sans filtre
vaincre pour 20% de rabais ce qui est un
énorme pourcentage de rabais pour vos
achats donc profitez-en
cette semaine on reçoit kim lizotte qui
est humoriste scénariste a écrit entre
autres la sérénissime on ne connaissait
peut-être qui va voir une belle série
c'est bien très bientôt sur nouveau dans
vos écrans khimki une nouvelle adepte
vous savez pas de casse en fait que
commencer à nous écouter puis à des
audits puis cédera pas ce qui est arrivé
ici avec plein de points dont elle
voulait discuter de choses quand on n'y
serait pas de casse sur lesquelles elle
voulait revenir puis c'est comme ça la
fait une petite analyse analyse
psychologique de nos personnalités fait
que c'était vraiment comique en fait de
moi quelqu'un qui arrive ici avec un peu
d'aidé
d'une idée sur pierre plus challenging
antenne aux idées vraiment l'fun c'était
comme si un espèce de retour sur plein
de podcasts qu'on a fait débat dans
certaines idées une fille super super
allumé super énormément d'énergie qui
vraiment présente avec kit débattre un
petit peu pu discuter d'un grand plaisir
de larceveau y est ce juste avant en
fait d'aller remercier nos annonceurs on
veut juste dire que on loue le studio
sf6 ou est-ce qu'on est présentement on
est en processus de déménagement ce
moment fait qu'on va agrandir les locaux
ils vont plus d espace pour plus de sept
heures de studio donc aller voir ça au
studio 7.0 ça vous intéresse puis le 11
valaisan maman pour nos sponsors le
votre caf est présenté par world de rim
et yeux bleus connaissent et ils nous
commande est souvent ils font des
produits alimentaires pour chiner
produits où elle vend des produits
hypoallergène pour votre petit votre
petit pitou le petit chien ou un énorme
et colosses
donnez-lui les produits wadder 8 les
produits innovants les produits pour les
rejoindre
t à base de protéine alternative en des
gâteries à base de poudre de grillon
abas abaz d'agde de la gaspésie à base
de purées cycliques sont pas utilisés
pour faire des ducs ont fait des
conneries avec ceux des produits
éco-responsables csu pas qu ils font
aussi de la nourriture à base d'insectes
de la nourriture à base de carpes
asiatiques qui est en fait un poisson
qui doit être pêchés pour conserver les
fonds marins dont travaille
conjointement avec des pêcheurs
nord-américain pour s'assurer d'avoir
des sources de protéines éco responsable
on a un code promo pour vous autres qui
le sf vang bon 20 % de rabais si vous
allez sur leur site web mon chien sauve
le monde point ca avec merci la gamme de
wilder greer puis honnêtement à l'échec
est ce parce que à chaque fois qu'on
parle de lui et du monde qui nous disent
qu'ils ont achetés soit pour leurs
chiens pays trip eux mais aussi la chine
fait aller voir sa fille mercy la gloire
locale
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
nos amis chez mindscape qui sont la
compagnie ultime pour l'entretien sous
la ceinture qui viennent toujours de
lancer leur quatrième génération du
performance package qui comprend le
l'ombre 4.0 leurs instruments vraiment
important dort ça vaut en fait sous l'os
est waterproof une technologie qui vous
empêche de nick et l ict parties intimes
puis ça peut être aussi être utilisé
pour la baby plusieurs niveaux en fait
de garde qui vous permet de vous mettre
un petit peu de ce talent ça vient avec
un déodorant peau les boys et un petit
tour nord kivu ravive ça ça vient même
avec des boxeurs puis s'y connectent pas
qu'en fait de moi j'utilise le mot aussi
sur la ceinture aux tambours malbars
mais si vous préférez le est un petit
peu place à cuire et d'hommes à ce qu'il
vous faut les y aussi le hull trop
souvent qu'un jeune kroos mousse c'est
en fait un petit gaulois à la mode
j'aime bien la lame pour ce qui vraiment
de les parties intimes que ce soit le
vraiment de plus le plus beau possible
non dit qui l'est tout petits le rail
est vraiment facile à manier à cette
région là et puis j'ai jamais été aussi
doux de toute ma vie
vraiment une cystite une révolution on
en attend que de bon feedback le pied
puis vous êtes beaucoup aussi à l'enfant
l'accusée l'acquisition n'y avait qu'une
t'écrivant privée et ça marche vraiment
bien
les produits manneken pis moi j'ai
aucune
j'en parle à tout le monde se répand la
bonne nouvelle les pros du manuscrit
vraiment révolutionnaire sa voix
extrêmement blé si vous êtes un adepte
des
les kundera bien photo bien entretenu
vraiment c'est des produits qu'il faut
piège porte parfois nous importe les
boxeurs de manière assidue
j'ai mis en rotation c'est vraiment on
pourrait plus recommandés on a un code
promo pour vous autres qui est le sans
fil quand un mot c'est 20 % de rabais
plus le shipping gratuit donc un énorme
rabais
allez voir s'appuie plus jamais vous
allez vous allez utiliser à nos produits
en fonte meersman skate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrête ça tourne
bienvenue à sa cause c'est un peu à
cause d'un état des jardins pas me dit
mais tu devrais écouter lui puis lui
pillu et puis quand on rentre dans un
loupé
puis moi j'écoute des podcasts pour man
dormait parce que vous vous endormez là
mais parce que ça ça me calme ppt en
hausse jeudi je sais comme et
inconsciemment des fautes laine café
d'eiffage pas d'accord mais j'aime
souhaite pas d'accord avec vous vous
invitez vrai que j'aimerais ce genre
intervenez bientôt je t'écris d'accord
c'est ce que je pense que ça va être
l'invité qui va être le plus préparé ou
sans fil
je vais l'écouter à la fois plus cher
faut qu'on soit en vacances parlons-en
parce que c'est encore plus demandés sur
analysé sais pas ce que je fais ça dans
la ville faisant danser avec mes temps
avec mes amis et les gens avec qui je
travaille
ça me fera pas de rentrer dans comment
mon cerveau fonctionne mais il ya comme
quelque chose dans mon cerveau qui fait
que je peut décortiquer rapidement
quelqu'un je réduis une psychologue
marié trop tard pour tourner aux études
faire ce mets toutes mes amies qui
défilent venaient me parler de leurs
problèmes mais mais vous vu que vous
vous livrez beaucoup vous êtes tellement
vulnérable peux vous parler tellement de
vue personnel que tu mon cerveau serait
juste un clash on avait tellement on est
devenu une mamie de même il même à cause
de taux faudrait que je dis ça mais je
dis répond je connais pas assez pour
penser que c'est une folle c'est à dire
tout ce que bright food
oui je me suis je prépare serait pas de
casse qui commentent vos patins
vraiment plus populaires mais pas bien
c'est pas eu cette capsule a commenté
youtube laissé comme un deux trois
heures avec dijon metz parce que ça
n'est pas de qui vous rencontrez quand
vous rencontrez des spécialistes c'est
tellement intéressant parce que je sois
comme ouvert jusqu'à une période de jeu
vous êtes trop analysé comme une espèce
de croisée des chemins dans votre vie ou
qui comme le podcast vous ça presque de
thérapie comme pour tout ça vous en
ligne que vous rencontrez des gens que
vous avez différentes donc ça fait en
sorte que même si des fois je pas
d'accord avec ce que vous dites je suis
juste comme ailleurs où ou des fois
quand je suis complètement d'accord
shrek vous êtes dans l'ouverture avec
votre invité est vraiment est peu comme
l'opposé de ce serait jean mathieu
bock-côté mais arrive tout son sens des
fêtes
il va toutes lettres la pitch effet
seulement est dans un débat théologique
ouais ok il crée semblant d'être dans un
débat mais il pas dans un débat aussi
son idée est faite pour nous ne
changerons pas dans le segment bonne
pendant laquelle ils exposent je ferai
jamais changé d'idée puis capable de ce
bac mais vous mettons ça vous dit
quelque chose
je sens que le sh100 metop les
spécialistes l'ont invité que vous avez
rang qui est ici avec vous hassan ouvert
ce bourg faire mais moi je pense
autrement fait que pour ceux que j'aime
votre podcast meti est belle et merci
mais c'est au début mais justement on y
est souvent comme toi pas d'accord avec
tout ce qui est dit mais si on n'est pas
confrontation mais n'est pas comme ben
non c'est pas ça c'est comme acquis pour
quoi tu penses ce qui est toujours une
raison pour lesquelles les gens sont
comme son bip ans comme une pense
maintenant c'est ce que j'explique est
intéressant je trouve le temps de
comprendre mais souvent aussi pis c'est
probablement ce que je trouve qu'il le
plus
une des choses les plus intéressantes du
format podcast c'est que tu réalises que
même si tu est en désaccord avec avec la
personne sur une affaire pue mais tendue
peut être fondamentalement des accords
dont on a on est excité par aversion en
parlant de ceux plus tard le met le
paquet en effet guillaume dulout le trio
est ce qu on voit ce qu'on se marre
amine consentement piqué clairement la
vision qu'on a deux comment s'est
exprimé c'est pas on n'a pas la même
vision de comment l'exprimer
par contre quand tu réalises caen 4-2 le
format podcast comme ça sans montage qui
permet d'exposer une conversation
complet sur alice que 95% du message on
pense la même chose que c'est les 5% ou
est ce qu on l'expriment pas de la même
façon peut-être où on pense carrément
pas la même chose sauf que ceux souvent
j'imagine que je pense qu'il faut
démocratiser geste est en désaccord sur
des quais à fond parce que pendant
podcast le temps le thème si je perds je
trouve que l'espèce de mode des podcasts
et comme une réponse à l'instantanéité
des réseaux sociaux twitter 140
caractères lui fait lire les
commentaires sur facebook les statuts
facebook de moyens com
mais le podcast et comme sous l'eau
selon radio le son alors oui on attend
d'expliquer pendante aux nuances et puis
on a même ces mêmes montants c les
personnalités publiques qui ont le temps
d'exprimer qui sont pour vrai happy pas
dans un segment cinq minutes pour nous
ton était qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de ce
mois j'ai beaucoup de chroniques télés
radios passées tout le temps dis moi
tout ce que tu penses de l'immobilier en
six minutes du bulletin seigneur
toujours que tu résultats pense et puis
je trouve que le podcast sa vie comme
tout nuancer ce petit pécule et
longtemps quelqu'un parler en profondeur
d'un sujet qui maîtrisent le temps de
débattre tout le temps de dans la nuance
c'est vraiment ce que le contraire de la
télé puis contraire des réseaux sociaux
lui même pour ça ceci étant dit je suis
vraiment pas d'accord à lyon du lourd
puisque je vous aime parce qu'on se sait
aujourd'hui c'est juste à cause de ça
parce que tout ce qui a amené sur la
conscience match et comme je bouillais
intérieurement le plus urgent je vous
parlais dans mon salon chez comme non
non non non non tu parlais aux podcasts
en faisant il peut pas dire que ça se
peut pas je pense que sa vision la
patente est complètement erronée pis je
vais remettre américaine globalement que
ta mémoire est plus fraîche que la nôtre
soleil conversation là parce que tu es
nous on ne la conversation pee wee piste
le lendemain on va passer à autre chose
selon le progrès entendu on le pourrait
coûter quitter notre vision de soi pas
nécessairement changer je me souviens
qu'il ya eu des prises de bec mais il ya
eu 10 ty une différence de point de vue
des pignons j'ai envie que tu l'avais
comme ramener parce qu'ils étaient comme
c'était au temps la personne à l
responsabilité de la femme et de l'homme
ce espèce de truc de consentement mais
c'est sûr que dans un monde idéal où les
hommes et les femmes on était go on est
complètement dans une relation 50/50
piqué tout est pris en considération
mais c'est pas ce qui se passe la
majorité du temps quand on y apprend le
consentement c'est quelqu'un qui a le
dessus sur l'eau comme dans la société
dans laquelle on vit et on n'est pas
dans une société égalitaire puis je
trouve que son discours parce que je les
ai entendus sur d'autres choses après
puis son discours c'est comme si on fait
dans un monde où l'égalité était déjà
acquise
mais c'est comme c'est beau c'est la
réelle je pense que vous faites juste le
ramener là dessus moment donné en dix
ans mais ça peut pas je sais que la
responsabilité de la fille parce que les
com ni le rapport de pouvoir dont il
fait complètement pays je trouve
irresponsable en fait comme il ya quand
même quelque chose dans ce qu'ils
disaient qui moi m'a paru comme
nécessaire a ajouté à la conversation
parce que ce que tu dis je suis 100%
d'accord le mais le point qui a amené
indien que
que dans la société dans laquelle on est
les femmes sont se font apprendre à
plaire à tout prix ce sujet comme
réalisé que pendant qu'on en parlait
j'ai complète crise c'est vrai que c'est
un énorme problème parce que
probablement que il ya des situations
parce que le consentement et comme flou
parce qu'elle est la femme se fait dire
bel homme
je vais accepter ce qui se passe même si
finalement ça me tente pas tant que ça
parce qu'il faut que je plaisent à
l'homme qui fait que cet aspect là de
déconstruire le rapport de loin à un
tabernacle de déconstruire à apprendre
aux femmes à ne pas plaire à ne pas
vouloir plaire à tout prix tu trouvais
que ce point là c'est quand même
intéressant dans la façon qu'il a mené
c'est pas la faute les responsabilité
bâtissent pas la faute de la femme de
lui comme ça c'est le site ici comme le
site l'essentiel qui est la piste tout
ce qui a été véhiculé comme metz avait
encore une fois qu'ils ont autant qui
fait que ben cette réaction le husa veut
pas de ce parti ne viens viens ici
justement de vouloir plaire mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut déconstruire ce mais
c'est pô juste à la halle aux chances
écran du latran du léger comme le
feeling qu'on accuse un peu des mouches
c'est dans le discours global puis que
peut-être
attardons-nous à la section principale
avant maculé une déconstruction à faire
avant d'avoir une relation sexuelle il
ya déjà c'est mais justement c'est pour
ça que je parle beaucoup à ndiass et
ainsi on trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
dynamiques peuvent être mal seul mais
que c'est dur c'est de décortiquer est
ce que je sens une relation toxique au
juste dans un couple qui dans une phase
difficile
est ce que c'est moi que de la misère à
affirmer mes besoins ou c'est l'autre
qui manipulent c'est vraiment du sud de
décortiquer peas et arrive jusqu'à la
ligne
la ligne est mince mais je pense plus on
peut faire l'éducation puis plus les
femmes vont se parent entre realp et
plus les hommes vont être ouverts au
disco plus on va être capable de
décortiquer se dit souvent ça dans les
podcasts et que c'est quoi la ligne
entre ça va bien avec ma blonde où ça va
pas bien ou c'est fini ou c'est pas fini
houston et fidélité qu'ils pardonnent
l'infidélité qu'ils pardonnent pas
cc puis je pense qu'on peut je pense
qu'on peut tous ensemble essayer de
mettre des espèces de code puis de
bosses et de se comprendre pour
justement qui est moindre que ce soit
moins floue petit qu'on soit capable de
dire non ce que tu vis en ce moment
c'est ce que tu fais en ce moment c'est
pas normal puis il ya une dynamique qui
pas qui pose juste piqué au lieu de
faire juste acheté dans un couple qui
savent pas ou n'en changent de
consentante mais n'en jetez pas
consentant mais j'aurais dû plus là elle
affirmé c'est toute cette zone grise là
je pense qu'on est dans une bel air pour
s est essayé de mettre les les codes
plus clair pour moi c'est plus fun pour
tout le monde justement se sent mieux en
fait c est ce qu il ya quand même de ces
deux du propre à chacun dans ces choses
lorsque mettons chez qui des gens dans
des dents des relations qui cherchent
des relations conflictuelles pas
conflictuel mais des relations challenge
round qui vont tes avoir déraillé peu
abordé l'eau puis à d'autres mondes qui
cherchent de quoi vraiment plu puisque
stable avec des - ouais mais des moins
bons lotina tant pis puis de dire est-ce
qu'on peut arriver à 1
un constat global de savoir qui est ce
parce qu'il a tout mentionnait la
normalité thisday qu'est ce qui est
normal dans une relation mais il existe
une c'est la normalité dans une relation
je pense anormalité je pense que l'
équilibre peut arriver mais je pense que
vous dites souvent c'est connais toi toi
même si c'est un peu ça craque plus tu
connais toi même s'ils se rencontrent
quelqu'un qui se sent mais y'a comme il
ya vraiment un truc de ce milieu de plus
tu connais plus de 6 ce que tu veux plus
te connais tes besoins en plus fait
plutôt des relations dans la vingtaine
plus expérimenté un moment donné tu
étais capable d'établir ce que tu veux
dire qu'avoir d'établir que tout besoin
tu finis par comprendre à peu près quel
genre de personne que de besoin
d'environ puis avec cette personne là
après tu peux établir ce que tout besoin
du suspense je pense pas que c'est le
mariage qui a rendu les gens malheureux
je pense que c'est d'établir que tout le
monde devait se marier avoir des enfants
pour être différents modèles mais fois
capable de s'épanouir dans toutes ses
modèles
je pense que différents modèles en ce
moment que son intérêt ça n'y ait pas de
s'épanouir dans tous ses modèles d'eau
capable de trouver le modèle dans lequel
on s'épanouit le plus fou trouvé de
modèle dans lequel on s'explique alors
tu sois bien là dedans quelqu'un qui
répond à ce puits c'est comme mais c'est
ça qui peut être intéressant parce que
c'est rare qu'elle y brille toujours un
peu moins jusqu'à pas que tu sois bing
soit heureux parce que de toute façon
quand je tombe en amour est quelque
chose de tellement chimique pin
mystérieux qui atténue deal avec se
retrouver avec la personne pour que ça
fonctionne que trouver quelqu'un ça
marche sur papier en théorie puisque
finalement mai mais que le fils potins
on sait comment ça c'est ma vision de
l'amour mais ça mais à chacun son chemin
j'essaie d'aller poser ma vision des
choses je me dis dans ma qu'hakim à
chacun son chemin le à chacun
quand j'ai vu jonathan roy keane ici le
jeter comme membres gold c'est comme
l'homme le plus libre que j'ai vu de
merville m'attendais poas parce qu'il
l'a tellement pas été longtemps mais pas
par la nature de bt 2 il était
prisonnier du du d'une image en images
le spectre de son parti il était
prisonnier l'adapt la seconde qui a
décidé de sortir de ce fait acquis non
le sait les gérer
je veux goûter à tout je veux vivre tout
pipi il donne sept mètres parce que
c'est ce qui c'est pour ça que c'est un
homme du futur parce qu'il y est capable
disco logiquement de donner cette
liberté là sa blonde mais moi ce que
j'aime pas c'est qu'en ce moment il ya
plein de modèles différents qui arrive
mais il y en a un des deux qui se pile
dessus pour plaire à l'eau au nom d'une
liberté
puis au nom de l'identité de l'autre
piste froide assez faut vraiment être
assez assez assez conscients de ce qu'on
veut puits de secours n'est plus de ce
qu'on vaut procureur de dire si ça me
convient ça me convient pour ce qu' il y
avait fait plein podcast avec des femmes
d'à peu près 30 ans qui m'ont beaucoup
confronté parce que je me disais
j'entendais dans leur discours m'a dit
je prête à accepter ce mais j'étais
comme banque était prête à accepter ce
au nom de l'amour mais je pense je sens
que fondamentalement c'est pour ce voeu
puis je sais comme sur les écrans
oui oui mais des fois c'est comme via
wifi quand mais je serai peut-être
capable dans une relation ouverte mais
je le sens je lai 5 c'est comme pour pas
perdre son charme à tous prier comme
peep show ça je le sens des fois puis-je
tanks et des gars qui sont assez
manipulateur pour faire croire à l'autre
que c'est une décision comme on avait
parlé quinquin horse une diam's est
quelque chose qui meurt c'est quelque
chose qui fait vraiment beaucoup de
chemin dans ma tête en fait c'est la
vision collective qu'on a de l'amour
avec un grand a comme valeur suprême qui
roule tout le reste le tir comme étant
quelque chose que la fameuse image de
l'homme sort qui existeraient quelque
bord qu une fois qu une fois que je
trouve cette personne ne tombe en amour
c'est unique s'assure trop dur poppy moi
j'ai de la misère avec conception c'est
selon mais exact sommes non mais non
seulement ça n'existe pas sauf que
l'idée qu'on s'en fait quand même deux
cas mais tonte et étaient prêts à
accepter de la marde en tabarnak parce
que tu aimes quelqu'un voici fille puis
ça marche pas se trouve que quand tu es
dedans c'est dur je le sais je me suis
le premier à tomber en amour puis à
avoir rien voir le acquis à rien voir et
puis question pour toi ben parlons-en
justement l'amour je vois rien du tout
quand je cherche quelqu'un qui vient de
se passer comme si en claquant des yeux
tu te réveilles trois ans plus tard la
même personne qui est à ses côtés
pourquoi tu as accepté la frappe était
la forme telle affaire pourtant
fermeture fait tu reviens sur ta
relation bleus de cette crise finalement
j'ai accepté par la peur parce que je me
disais juste en amour mais si c'est
tellement pas conquête est tellement
abstrait ceci concerne la dame et c'est
l'espèce qu'est ce que je fais qui est
un compromis dans piqué ce que je fais
je le fais contre moi parce que c'est
malsain mais en même temps mais ce qui
est maintenant livré une dure puisque
ndiaye et moi on parle souvent ces
espèces de le truc la fiction ce que ça
a eu sur nous au delà du conte de fées
du prince charmant l'espèce d'une
relation supposée d'être en mouvement
pour chercher l'eau depuis il était
recherché puis l'espèce de
les papillons que ça donne mais c'est
papillon là ça peut être juste un stress
aussi
tu fais en sorte que tu es en train de
te faire manipuler pilote est capable
d'avoir une emprise sur toi puis le
petit boum boum boum qui arrive c'est
c'est la peur de perdre l'autre c'est la
peur de l'abandon des fois c'est la peur
d'avoir de voir son ego est blessé puis
on finit par mélanger tout ce
mais mettez ces les relations étaient
plus claires si les gens capitale
établissant leur besoin puisqu'ils sont
pour vrai psion pouvoir une coupe
demanipulator du chemin fille qui font
le reste pour vous les bongo mais je
points et tendance est gentil quand même
mais dans non mais ça féret ça françois
que ce serait plus facile mais faut
arrêter de penser c'est moi j'ai j'ai eu
une pause au moment donné avec mon homme
parce qu'il y avait quelque chose dans
la dynamique marchait plus puis il m'a
couru après pendant trois mois passés a
rétabli notre dynamique
puis ça a changé notre relation de coupe
pour le mieux mais j'ai souvent des amis
qui ceux qui prennent ça comme exemple
c'est pas la norme
oui je fais comme ça n'arrive jamais
comme l'exception qui confirme la règle
les spots honte si j'ai des amis qui ont
en fait un winch bien se laisser mon
corps après moi bon il valoir
quant à trois amis qui font ce jusqu'au
peut pas faire puis j'ai dit tu ne vois
pas ça parce qu'en plus moi quand j'ai
fait ça je partis pour rien n'y avait
pas de check bénéfices étaient comme
finale finale fait qu'ils n'aient pas
j'essaye pas de jouer une game mais
c'est aussi ça c'est parce qu'il a la
seconde que tes amis commencent à faire
sur sa tombe en mode manipulation billet
un peu malsain impulser la dynamique de
mal c'est ni té vologe côté rociste de
faire ça dans le but d' quels autres
charges ousty les gens qui changent
réellement terry des aspects de leur
personnalité ou de dayton qui ont
extrêmement rares actifs sûrs tout en
avançant en âge mais c'est ce qui compte
près de toi parce que je peux conseiller
à des mets mes amis j'en remets ton jeu
ne sera jamais parfaite relation sera
jamais parfaite mais vous pouvez
travailler là dessus puis vous pouvez
vous apporter beaucoup
puis même si vous êtes différent ou même
si vous avez des profs c'est le fond de
pensée ne pense rires parce qu'après tu
es tellement plus soudée mais il faut
quand même que je connaisse
le conjoint de mon ami pour faire comme
dans cet être investi de manipulateur
qui s'est passé ce qui veut quitter
prêter prix là dedans c'est malsain
mais si on est capable d'en parler parce
que j'ai des amis des fois qu'il voyait
pas simple quand je disais tu cries
manipulateur ça parle comme ça fait six
professeurs du casting puis tu sais si
tu dis tu es trop sensible dans le fond
puis là je sens que mon ami tu es j'en
ai eu des amis que je sentais que
c'était niais qui devenait l'ombre
d'elle-même qui finissaient par s'isoler
puis phares comme moi mais je veux que
ça marche puis je veux qu'ils m'aiment
puis d'enfoncer mois et qu'il met il
qu'ils prenaient ce réel peut-être que
tu fasses aussi l'espèce de sessegnon
qui est trop sensible peut-être que
c'est moi qui est qui qui est pas
capable de deal avec ça c'est peut-être
moi qui passe est ouverte elle juge
pourrait s'ouvrir sexuellement peut-être
que je poche que bon le soleil mais non
mais non mais des fois tu vois quelqu'un
est en train de disparaître puis puis
moi mon message c'est un choisi toi
maman données choisi trois pistes vo pas
tout perdre
pis pour ceux qu'ils aiment créé tous
les jours pour que j'écrive un mot du
livre qui s'appelle choisi toi j'ai
tellement d'amis qui ont besoin
d'entendre ceux choisis toi puisque aux
règles imposées des affaires jean et moi
je vais l'exclusivité
si ça se trouve elle vouloir exclusivité
parce que moi j'ai le goût de la donne
et fait que je peux tu la recevoir en
retour
ça veut pas dire d'être dans un conte de
fées je pense qu'on va être toute la vie
ensemble qu'on ira jamais vos railleur
mais si c'est pour ça que je te dis que
tu es polyamoureux moquette mix of china
great wall e kung fu lee amoureux je
pense pas je pense pas que parce que
dans le polyamour il ya aimer plusieurs
personnes
ouais en même temps moi si moi je pense
pas que je vais être capable de faire ça
mais je sais pas peut-être carnet savard
avait pu voir réaliser que c'est quelque
chose qui se peut mais moi c'était passé
j'ai tiré prétend pas polyamoureux le
nid que je pense c'est que ce que je
pense
ben dans
les futures relations au flore que je
travaille en fait d'un travail contre
intuitif de ma part de de vouloir avoir
un dialogue ouvert par rapport à ces
choses ah oui ouais mais ok je vois tu
analyses et pis toi tu le connais depuis
janvier temps exaucé j'ai raison parce
que quand j'étais content parce que tant
par beaucoup ce sont ces écoutes tout
les cas ce qu'on a fait dans le dernier
mais il ya comme un truc j'ai
l'impression je pense que tu ai vécu un
petit roman je sais pas si tu es
fêteront peu mais ce pas de mes affaires
je pense que vécu quelque chose puis ton
côté rationnel essai de tellement
intellectualiser la douleur que tvq pour
pu la revivre puisque je me reconnais là
dedans parce que je me trompe pas c'est
ce que je me suis dit on essaye on
dirait que tu étais tellement de
l'intellectualiser tu ton cerveau et de
tellement trouver une solution pour plus
jamais terme dans cette situation le
qu'ils étaient prêts à faire c'était le
couple vend c'est peut-être le polyamour
c'est comme fou que je me back mais ma
réponse à seuls deux grandes sages du
japon c'est quand on va trouver
quelqu'un qui va être rassurant le pian
qui sort confiance s'ils vont pouvoir
avoir une exclusivité en imaginant que
s'ils arrivent ci arrive quelque chose
fait capable de passer au travers avec
la personne sait qu en tête avec
quelqu'un qui te rassure peau qui port
assurant 400 qui est sûr c'est quelqu'un
qui est trop dans la séduction c'est
quelqu'un qui est que briser la
confiance quelqu'un de puissant qui peut
mentir le ne peut pas voir les trouve
être dans l' hyper vigilant ce projet
mais dans l'espèce de est ce que je vis
dans une relation ouverte puisque je
veux est-ce que je pense qu'on peut se
permettre d'aller voir ailleurs que de
juste à être éligible d'être à 100% avec
toi qu'on bâtisse en somme à 100%
qu'on soit vraiment une vraie intimité
qu'on partage un bout de notre vie
ensemble et nous et non messieurs les
sofas comme là je vais laisser toutes
les portes ouvertes
puis je voudrais tout puisque aurait que
j'ai eu depuis plus rien qui me fait mal
pays mais je te dis ça parce qu'aimer
réflexion j'ai eu vraiment longtemps
pour que justement pur pause souffrir
puisque plus jamais personne la phase de
perdre parce que ce que tu dis là je l'
ai réfléchi j'ai pensé à
la possibilité existe est peut-être pour
ce oui je me dis ça parce que oui ça
m'est arrivé de me faire tromper puis
oui j'avais le réflexe de dire le jeu
puis ça arrive jamais sauf qu'après
c'est en réfléchissant ce la réflexion
n'était pas sur le faire physiquement
trompé c'était sur une face cachée des
affaires en grave jamais que ça revienne
jamais fait une fois que ce j'ai réalisé
ce je me suis dit ah qui fait que c'est
pas parce que je veux me protéger moi
c'est juste parce que dans ma prochaine
relation quand je te cache pas le couple
hoover mettons pile c'est juste d'avoir
le dialogue transparent wind absolument
à tout prix à tout prix pied après ce
mois la sexualité dans ma vie c'est
important mais c'est pas la chose la
plus folle la chose principale dans une
relation ne s'est pas partie des
quelques affaires qui sont vraiment
importants mais c'est pas la chose la
plus important puis je veux pas que
cette chose là qui devant mes yeux
soient pas la chose la plus importante
vienne briser toutes les autres affaires
qui font que ça fonctionne c'est fake
c'est ce que je veux c'est ce que je
veux et éventuellement dans mes
relations
c'est exactement ce que tu veux c'est de
la dette en relation avec quelqu'un avec
qui j'ai la confiance
ultime qui avait qui chez que en fait
d'emblée établir une relation où est-ce
que yo rien il ya aucune information qui
va m'être donnée qui va risquer tout
chambouler faites juste de pouvoir se
sentir complètement libres 2 et badauds
et your hair s'est passé ça tu le sais
étaient au courant maintenant
puis après ça ça devrait tout d'abord
mes arguments
je veux pas qu'on scrap tout ce qu'on a
ça parce que c'est pas assez important
dillon ex mais ça veut pas dire je veux
s'appliquant si je veux pas dire on
rentre dans la relation que c'est comme
ok on peut
coucher avec n'importe qui n'importe qui
empirent ça me dérange pas puisque c'est
pas ça c'est pas comme ça que je le vois
mettons mais je le vois de comme si ça
arrive parce que oui parce que moi je
peux dire que je suis un peu cynique
mais j'ai le feeling qu'il faut un peu
se mettre la tête dans le sable de
penser que dans une relation sur une vie
au complet doit être fidèle
nancy tout le temps moi je pense que
c'est hypocrite de passer ça fait qu en
se disant ça va arriver
ben au moins si on sent qu'on est la
transparence absolue de quand ça arrive
quant à hossa en parle depuis ou même un
petit jo jo est bon c'est mon studio du
roi c'est un ami à moi petit mettant
décoration comme on a eu sur le podcast
à écouter insiste t on en a à toutes les
fois où est-ce qu'on se voie oui puis
non mais il peut y avoir des hauts et
des bords lui aussi même d'en bas non
mais y en a je garantis cannois
sauf que sauf que l'idée de ce design
aussi mettons que la tête avec une
personne petite taille je commence à
peut-être développer quelque chose ou
quelqu'un d'autre
ainsi ceux qui partent en premier oui
mais je veux le savoir quand je veux
savoir mais ce parce que si ça a réalisé
on veut remettre remettons notre
relation sur le banc des accusés en
disant qu'ils le tuent développe quelque
chose pour quelqu'un d'autre
excuse parce que tu m'aimes moins un
mois si la réponse est oui
ben là c'est ok mais si tu m'aimes -
mois terminons notre relation pis
poursuit notre si la réponse est non je
t'aime autant l'offre d'une vraie
question à se poser
oui le csk québec - mettons le jeu ça
fait une heure que je parle d'eux et
lisa j'aime ça mais c'est que le tu dis
parce que j'ai réfléchi énormément dans
l'est la dengue les derniers deux
semaines le plus strict et si ton amour
pour la personne demeure inchangé son
amour pour toi demeurer changé mais que
développe des sentiments pour quelqu'un
d'autre
oui qu'est ce qu'on fait avec sa maman
va toujours 10,4 en parler de l'amour
inconditionnel pour deux enfants tués à
me disais tiens on est quatre dans ma
femme et quatre enfants qui a dit tu
divises pas l'amour par deux une barre
deux par deux tu toth un tout autre
nouvel amour pur à 100% pour un autre
afin permettons que la même relation
avec la personne qui était là même amour
des deux côtés mais que cette personne
développe quelque chose pour quelqu'un
d'autre
l'autre une vraie conversation à avoir
est ce que c'est quelque chose que je
capable de vivre avec c'est de partager
cette personne le ou à quelqu'un d'autre
oui enfin partager c'est ça la france
parce que l'autre personne a un choix à
faire en se disant est ce que je donne
de l'importance à ce qu'est ce que tu
dis parce que ça se peut tomber en amour
avec quelqu'un d'autre mais complètement
faire comme je pense que tout puis vous
ça va falloir que ça finisse pas ce que
je peux capable mais avec le temps des
fois tu te rends compte qu'un kit qui
savent pas ce qu'ils apportent chaque x
a passé j'ai des amis qui donne une
importance à chaque tension qui vivent
en faisant un résumé lieu peut-être que
je suis est nommé ce sens du club si tu
fais rien je pense que dans deux
semaines sa femme et vous à lyon que je
me voyais ning et simon et voyons on a
essayé m'intéresse même pas mais des
fois mais parce que des fois faut pas
donner trop d'importance des fonds peut
avoir comme une surcharge une espèce de
clic de 1 my god
ça fait du bien et puis moi et on espère
qu période qui m'a fait beaucoup de bien
avec seul le sait a dit la fidélité
c'est sûr impôt injuste contre l'autre
mais c'est un nouveau regard sur soi et
que ça rien à voir mais justement comme
tu dis ça rien à voir avec l'autre
exception quand dans une relation stable
où tu es heureux parce qu'on associe
beaucoup les finalités h8 pas satisfaits
dans mon propre look
des fois c'est pour ce défaut et manque
quelque chose personnellement j'étais
fou tu as besoin d'un nouveau regard
surtout des fautes est pris dans un
affaire pi soit vraiment et est
quelqu'un que de faire ressentir qu'ils
votent à porter un nouveau regard big
bang est commun comme dit espère 7e
reconnecte sur ton nez rouge vissé le
moteur de la vie mais c'est valorisant
mais t'es tu peux y aller dans ça peut
faire du bien
c'est un peu comme tout comme un peu
fille déçu pu faire comme peut mener
faire comme je veux je vois pas là parce
que ce que j'ai je tiens à ces vigies
pense que souvent on est justement
obligé d'en parler parce que moi je
pense comme toi / mettons il se passe
quelque chose mon show met en voyage il
se passe en affaires et puis je veux pas
savoir g passe avant mais si je le sens
dans maison lui c'est moche un peu
sorcière si je sens qu'il ya quelque
chose qui se passe je veux tout savoir
mais tu penses poc
donc si mais oui mais non pour le centre
ce messie
ouais mais peut-être pas mes bagages
messi mais c'est comme tu dis chiche qui
serait shift et par quelqu'un d'autre
la saison
je veux qu'on s'assoit qu'on en parle
c'était juste une tension temporaire
mais c'est aussi ce que c'est juste
exprès pour ça je pense que je capable
d'un peu tout accepter parce que je me
dis parce que quand tu prends la
décision je vais take two 10 on allait
enfin je consomme moins de 20 ans 30 ans
en jeu peut pas faire tout ce chemin là
en temps arrivera rien d'abord au dos
puis faut en parler quand ça va bien
c'est ce qui est au club ce serait pas
tellement bien lotis vraiment parler des
fidélités louis pire c'est qu'on voit là
c'est vraiment le moment puis la
meilleure façon je pense être parler de
l'historique de l'autre pied puis moi en
plus j'ai comme un disque au contraire
on dit souvent que c'est un fidèle une
fois et fidèle à jamais mais moi je
trouve qu'il ya des gens qui ont un
fidèle qui ont tellement été traumatisé
de ceux qui t'ont que son fidèle ami
fidèle parce que dans ma vingtaine j'ai
fait de la peine à des gens que j'aime
pas ça comme je veux plus jamais revivre
ça de ma vie qui essaient sus de feeling
leur espèce de deux mètres si je sais
pas ce qu'il faut aussi puisqu'on peut
m'arriver dans le futur il faut jamais
comme voir sa vie comme quelque chose de
fermé mais faux faux faux est si on veut
des relations de couple qui dure plus
que deux trois ans faut comprendre que
moment donné par des discussions à avoir
pu il faut aussi comme un couple c'est
sûr choisir de se choisir peu importe
que se rencontrent les gens que je
connais qui sont vraiment fermées en mon
nom je me trompe c'est fini quand ça
leur arrive ce sont des boussoles ips
fait comme ah ben non mais non vaut pas
tout car c'est sa terre on peut tout
dire c'est ce qu'on a à faire là parce
qu'il se passe quelque chose qu'on sème
encore pire
des fois des fois ça fait du bruit trou
et quelques uns de ces six derniers mois
ouais mais c'est vrai que ça veut dire
break tout parce que justement mais toi
tu 10h40 avait une rupture dit tout
c'est comment tu tentes étaient comme
des communes et leurs d'authenticité de
vulnérabilité au filet et a pas que
j'avais accumulé que je me dise je peux
pas dire ça parce que si je dis ça c'est
terminé c'est sûr mais le site a fini
comme çà fêtait le tout a pu sortir
c'est comme donner un deuxième souffle
puis sa femme à se terminer quand même
pour d'autres raisons métier mais wade x
4 plus rien à perdre sélectifs ou les
malades à être sauf que si j'avais été
complètement en ait de plus jour 1a
accumulé tout se sait cet essai ne pas
accumuler je pense oui reçoit dans une
relation de ta cumul rien
ouais c'est ça la clé c'est parce que ça
finit toujours par payer quand quelque
chose qui tapent des choses que tu
acceptes et d'un peu de souplesse a
accumulé saqr bin hamman et ça ça oui
c'est comme pisser -selon ce processus
long et puis moi c'est oui c'est moi ccc
j'ai l'impression que je me connais
mieux que jamais on avance en
championnat par une expérience puis cgg
j'étais avec du monde dans le passé j'ai
vécu l'expérience que tiges si je me
remettrai jamais là dedans parce qu'avec
une fois puis j'ai fait acquis non ce ça
me convient pas si ceux ci se tape rang
mais c'est un long processus de paix
plus envie d expérience plus tard un
compte des gens [ __ ] t'es dans des
relations comme ce que je te refais on
revient connaît autant même si c'est
vraiment à ce type pour ce qui des des
relations ouvertes sont pas ouvertes sur
ces jo il a dit le sait ces frais sont
naturels
oui c'est 18 avec sa blonde était depuis
le début commence à se voir
c'était déjà comme ça puisse en parler
puis moi je vois seulement mais la
boisson de même c'est comme c'est juste
naturel temps inversement c'est site
pour toi l'exclusivité la fidélité je me
dis gamers lt nos métiers
ces cétacés exclusivité pour toi c'est
naturel naturellement déporté vers se
clôt personnes naturellement porté vers
ce bain fait un bon match tpiy
si un thème habib avoir une attirance
d'avoir certains atomes crochus si un
des deux parties et naturellement porté
vers quelque chose puis l'autre non
c'est dur et réconcilie wemmel et france
parce qu'on voudrait que j'aimerais se
questionner les gens parce que je sens
je sens quand on est tous un jour on
voit que je pense que dans cent ans fait
150 à 200 en retour être des gens à part
wal je pense qu'avec mais je pense qu'en
ce moment on en a pas on ne peut la
boîte à outils pour être capable de
vivre ça fait tellement mal parce qu'au
delà de la blessure d'ego de bâtir
quelque chose avec quelqu'un puisse et
le mans sont justement que c'est un
stade ça détruit la confiance puisqu'ils
partagent quelque chose plus ce qui fait
mal c'est d'y être partagé une intimité
avec quelqu'un d'autre quelque chose qui
nous appartient de prononcer les mêmes
mots de fait les mêmes gestes sur une
autre personne
je pensais que ce qu'on avait c'est un
système assez précieux pour qu'ils
fassent attention pis je pensais que
cette spéciale concept vous écris ptc
avec quelqu'un d'autre mais je comprends
que si on avait des super cerveau puis
qu'on était vraiment outils et
psychologiquement pour comprendre puis
l'intellectualiser que ton chemin peut
quand même thème et table on peut quand
même tu aimé à la folie être heureuse
avec toi mais que son amour fait juste
comme tease elle avec les enfants elle
est juste ressenti quelque chose
ailleurs nous affecte en rien mais ce
poste parce que je pense même qu'on le
vit à ce moment-ci y ait des gens qui
ont des stress post traumatique puisque
je tombe sur des textures des gens pee
wee pour revenir pour revenir spécial eu
l'idée du de les sedin diamé pour
revenir à ceux ci oui on grandit aussi
en se faisant démoniser l'infidélité
l'été puis c'est sûr que c'est si tu
étudies si ça vient naturellement sûr
que si tu te fais martelé une façon
d'être en cours qui est exclusive toute
ta vie si tu que la question jamais ce
qui va être naturel pour toi va être une
relation exclusive c'est quand même
important de se remettre en question
puis de se remettre nous mêmes en pitié
juste de s'asseoir et de faire bon qui
voici ce qui se fait qu'est ce que j'en
pense si j'essaie d'enlever tout ce qui
a été tout ce qui m'a été
balancé en pleine gueule toute la
construction de la construction sociale
qu'en est il de moi mais qu'est-ce que
je capable d'accepter puis qu'est-ce que
je capable de comprendre mais pour ce
que je voudrais que tout le monde en ce
moment on prend des papiers crayons
qu'on écrit sur un papier avec combien
une personne que j'ai besoin de coucher
par anim et on s'aime et on reste et
c'est autour de la table risquent
d'avoir des réponses mais parce qu'ils
arrivent à un moment mais tire
maintenant qu'on oublie le 20 à 30 ans
le may arrive à un moment c'est quand on
rencontre quelqu'un si quelqu'un te dis
d'emblée
bon j'ai vraiment besoin dans une
relation ouverte parce que je me connais
j'ai vraiment besoin de séduire beaucoup
je suis quelqu'un de très convoité du
jeu
si vous n'êtes peut-être très convoité
que vous avez un super pote glace et a
dit fille qui faisait plus chaud qu'un
pote de ces camps sordides et ça crée un
espèce de montagne puis tu as le droit
de te dire et j'ai envie d'en profiter
j'ai envie de but de signer puis je
serais pas capable dans une relation
stable en ce moment parce que je suis
bombardée de filles qui veulent me
rencontrer puis j'ai vraiment une force
de ma vie où je veux j'ai pas envie de
me caser
je vous lève à 100% quand je rencontre
quelqu'un tu le dis que dans cette phase
le petit peu tu peux te le permettre
pige pas ma sueur qui arrive un moment
où toute âme je sais pas oui c'est juste
un moment donné de rien petit et j'ai
même des anigo qui comprennent même pas
beaucoup que ce thème tout sans donner
de somme et je connais tout payé de
rambardes site est même pas capable dans
un moment d'intimité avec quelqu'un même
si roland plein de fitz extrêmement seul
mais la beauté de la chose et la beauté
de la chance parce que j'ai quelque
chose parce que c'est ça mais moi c est
moi j'étais tellement malheureux
célibataire je sais qu'une caresse
comment ça je suis malheureuse marché
comme jeu tellement fruits dans la vie
je rentre pas dans les conventions au
moins trente ans que j'avais même pas de
cellulaire je parle je n'ai pas de carte
de crédit je faisais j'étais pigiste
contre sur contre eux faisait des gorges
des fruits j'avais pas besoin
j'avais aucune pression
de marie faire des enfants d'avoir une
job stable je pouvais vivre mes pièces
par année
mais crise ou leur est cher monsieur
pourquoi jeux traditionnels comme ça
mais je changerai pas mon adn
une technique c'est même que india me
diagnostic et je t'ai demi sexuelle mais
ça me fait bizarre parce que des demies
sexuelle c'est comme c'est comme bill
autres j'entendis pour unis dans une
bombe dans un podcast ya dix mois ci a
pas de connexion je peux pas je pense je
suis comme besoin d'une connexion
émotive pour kingfisher de mécanique
mais nick wirth iv oui quand je tombe et
c'est le bâtard chaque homme je pense
qu'elle apparaît père de même où j'ai
pogné le plus puis miami heat et que mes
profites en oh my god jeter comme je
trouve et gognies jeu parce que je
connaissais peu je connecte pas que
personne n'avait plus je souffre c'est
aussi le oui c'est ça mais si ça mais
parce que c'est ce sentiment de solitude
extrême parce que tu fais comme crise
quand est-ce que je vais reconnecter
quelques défauts une rabat oui mais
parce que des fautes sort d'une relation
tu avais une vraie connexion était
déconnecté voudrait reconnecter du sud
comme dans ce que tu étais avec l'autre
mais ça prend du temps
si reconnecter avec quelqu'un puis bâtir
quelque chose puis partager son art
hâtif le jeu met en commun un livre mais
mais ça prend du temps que ça prenait
des formes qui faussent laisser le temps
de rencontrer l'autre aussi pilar temps
de trouver la bonne personne mais ce qui
parce que puis mais ce qui est beau
c'est que dans la trentaine le temps sma
allé tellement vite que tout les toutes
les questionnements de la vingtaine que
tu dis à comment faire pour être fidèle
toute ma vie plus comment je vais faire
puis comme ça je suis capable d'être 5
avec elsa ça disparaît parce que tu
regardes l'otan en gagnera juste cinq
heures pendant 40 ans et comme il
quelque chose que ça que ça a l'air
tellement que cette espèce de truc de la
vingtaine ou tu fais comme oh my god the
dream cette fille leur jeu vient ce goût
mais je pourrai jamais me rendre jusqu'à
5 45
mais on dirait que seulement le temps
qui file sa faveur qui disparaît peu t
plus devant un grand vertige de comment
je vais vraiment je vais être un super
tout ce temps le camp
je capable de tenir cette relation le
motivera exactement ce vertige le il
disparaît - disparaît de plus en plus je
l'avais vraiment plus jeune j'ai le
temps parle de recommencer comment qu'on
peut imaginer ce modèle une vie tpiy si
l'express en mode le gie fil d'une telle
manière qu'il est en couple
exclusif t oui c'est quoi au situation
je veux tout savoir
moi si j'étais encore l'excusé pige à
colmar alors comment bien là-dedans
popote dérangeait pas de déranger parce
déjà répulsion n'a fait que j'ai
absolument que j'aille voir ailleurs
pour non c'est juste bien là dedans sauf
que ma blonde on en parle c'est pas
comme juste par défaut c'est comme se
sont parlés force d'être ouverte
comment tu vois ce puits pittis a tout
le temps first days a été oh ben ça
serait peut-être une possibilité
toujours je pu imaginer dans un modèle
de ma fille la relation évolue et puis
finalement ça comme naturellement était
bien le fils je fais juste est juste une
dureté je suis le projet pas envie
d'aller voir ailleurs
elle n'est plus tout ça c'est juste
comme fait dommageable mais croit
surtout début mais elle a d'autres qu'au
début c'est règlement mlg moins de
vertiges de parce que je me dis si dans
cinq ans ou dans dix ans ça peut changer
on en reparlera du lhotse puis sa classe
et comme l'autre jour c'est vraiment à
me demander de passes suggère avec la
dernière fille avec qui tu fous chantage
aux organisations un peu chiant j'ai dit
je pense pas être la dernière avec qui
j'ai couché mais je pensais pas gagner
voilà seul avec qui je veux coucher à
huy un bernard lama a toutefois
promettre la dernière chose que je veux
coucher mais si l'autre preuve en est ce
parce que vous êtes un roman que vous
voyez longtemps sans vous êtes très
amoureux avec moi c'est bon c'est non
vraiment mais c'est si tout jeune avec
le wii on verra comment ça va super bien
pis puis justement c'est facile c'est
moi ou c'est pas la relation montant
ruse des dingues de à ses jeux ses cesmo
si jusque là la chose la plus moche il a
plu comme confortable j'ai vécu en même
temps latella mot est vraiment allé là
bas parce que c'est ça qui est important
je pense de dire de répéter c'est que tu
peux avoir de la passion pit pas voir la
passion longtemps le tout le monde qui
vient ici pts 17 jours 2-1 puis papillon
aux pauvres j'ai encore des papillons ça
fait 8 heures mais nier comme sms parce
qu'après les espèces de papillons des
débuts mon budget il est papillons des
débuts les débuts le haut c'est beau ça
peut s'arrêter du jour ou du jour au
lendemain
c'est comme un rsa c'est tellement
intense mais d'un coup qui arrête de
m'appeler va capoter manger j'aime ça
quand il ya une espèce de stabilité que
ce qui qui qui se construit petit 5
l'autre il sur le bord de te demander de
déménager avait tué pour acheter un peu
plus loin si moi je subis savoir que tu
peux compter sur quelqu'un est réputé
chipoter pas tout le temps c'est encore
des rires jackson
c'est ce qui me rend vraiment malheureux
c'est comme être ceux qui sont accros
papilles en éveil appuie les petits
papillons du début début parce que quand
tu pas cette phase la phase du
désenchantement monture en conclut tel
qu'il ait pitié sur vos terres de voir
comme toute sa perfection quand et
qu'avant de passer ce après il ya
vraiment un réel attachement été capable
de garder une vie ne pas trop tomber
dans la routine puis d'être surprendre
quand on est toujours at il dit de ne
jamais tomber dans un espèce de confort
cette passion le peut pour se prolonger
vraiment longtemps puis ça devient
vraiment un amour plus plus profond qui
vraiment intéressant si tu peux passer
deux ans mais tout cas que l'état d'eau
où je mets en récompense tout que la
mousse la chose la plus grave c'est
juste les temps c'est l'expérience
ravine coupe quand même tu arrives en
marge de ce fait acquis non la moss et
sais pas ce qui s'est construit quelque
chose à deux crises en europe 1 on peut
rencontrer autant de gens qu'on veut
maintenant aller beaucoup envie de
prendre et 5 enfants par jour si tu veux
mais ça change pas le fait que quand tu
meurs le adrian 21 2 3 grammes
exactement comme au xviiie siècle
tu fais pas tu penses quoi quinze pays
quand fermé du petit pont d'or à tout
jamais elle commence et où hakeim et il
va t'en reste est une 2 d'affaires comme
c'est moi je pense et pète je sais même
pas où le mettre
c'est juste génial 2-2 chaume luxe ont
vraiment significatif pour moi dans ma
vie puis il y en a que j'ai revu en 2015
si c'était mon premier tome avec qui
j'étais 4-1 puis avec qui j'ai eu le
premier avec qui j'étais en à part j'ai
tellement aimé puis pensez aussi le club
pour la vip on est marié mais finalement
non puis je crains les revues il me prit
dans ses bras le pishtaco on my god tout
l'amour qu'on avait un polo y est encore
là il vit encore c'était presque un
sentiment familial comme si vous voyez
comme quelqu'un que j'aime j'ai un mike
goss chez l'homme l'amour ça mord pas
vraiment mais randonnée les gens sont
stipulées bonne personne pour toi mais
mais l'espèce d'amour véritable de
quelque chose que tu es parti avec
quelqu'un ça reste longtemps sur ceux
qui se laissent pixels la haine et
l'amour ce n'est jamais bien loin
mais il ya quelque chose de dd vraie
connexion des vraies relations le même
site et multiplie dans ta vie ils vont
en avoir deux trois trous sa valeur je
n'ai pas relu chômage repartent avec les
filles de dégénération style chic pour
sa douce à cette double d'une personne
qui construit la race qui tapa choix
d'alpha value fund fonds tepa racing
team et jean mus ya tellement de ces
personnes là qui ont été dans important
dans ma vie qui auraient le goût wade
etc sont mis à me piquer dit on apprend
des bières sûreté souvent le 6 mai mai
puis chaque chaque personne une unicité
pas quelque chose de tellement wibro que
ses cimaises part c'est quelqu'un
d'important par ces quelques partager
ton histoire c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup le
couple pitt et serge bouchard a dit ça
fait 2001 que l'être humain s est essayé
toutes les modèles puis on retourne
toujours au bon vieux couple je suis
plus tempéré comme faux départ de la
monogamie on vit plus dans une époque de
monogamie mens tu dis je suis monogame
tpo monogame parce que tu pètes femme
blonde en taverne pig la mono
amis c'est une personne tamari tu fais
des enfants c'est pour la vie puis y'a
pus rien ne change pas de choï fait
comme un terreau maintenance la
monogamie et mimi notionnels ont suivi
le mans series c'est beau quand tu vois
quelqu'un avec qui tu as été ces camps
ont malgré tout c'est surtout ceux vus
malade je m'offre vu l'ampleur et ma
mère tu me vue puis tous comme c'est
quelqu'un avec qui tu es même projet de
parler parce que cela assistance est
tellement sur moi puis je trouve que
c'est ce qu'on devrait reparler du
couple ses pieds bots de c'est ce qui
est dommage mais ton par rapport au
livre de ndiol sais qu'il ya des gens
qui pensent qu'une relation
il faut que ça soit tu multiplies vie
qui sont pris parce que c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont bons les pervers narcissique
ce parce qu'ils font du lobbying justice
tu as l'impression de vivre un conte de
fées peut-être pas envie de te dire oh
c'est un conte de fées dans le fond
parce que je mérite pas vraiment d'être
aimé ça se peut pas des bongo fait c'est
quoi la ligne anglaise est en train de
faire loft boming avec des fleurs des
promesses vides l'engagement trop
rapidement clôture prend puis après ça
devient comme en montagnes russes et ça
peut durer des années j'ai des amis ça
fait des années que son prix là dedans
pis le suppute enfin mais c'est vraiment
difficile à voir à l'épi cancan c'est
tout intellectualiser pikit à 10 mais
c'est parce qu'on s'aime mais si on veut
se trouver mais pas facile puis
d'enfants puis il ya toujours ce
discours bien même dégoût que je savais
que les femmes en tailleur mais l'espèce
de nommer lui-même indiqué l'opie l'on
voit préfère la thérapie en 115 seul
amour pour ce temps dont je veux dire
pour marteler que la passion ça peut
être beau et ça peut être stable
blizzard contrôlé mon temps comme piqué
piquette peu l'avortoir les papillons et
de la passion puis du de la romance sans
que ça soit toxique
ça existe mais c'est long à trouver
parce que comme je disais tantôt une ou
deux trois quatre cinq personnes qui
vont être vraiment significative dans ta
vie mais c'est que le fait d'être
toujours en attente
la relation piqué le sabot peau mais ça
valait bien qu'à ainsi qu'un soutien qui
mènerait se sait ce qui peut prendre le
plus grave est flag ses saillies roja
n'est bien que dans mon expérience à
chaque fois qu'est ce tu connais
le site annonce quand ça va mal depuis
un an
mais ce qui m'a quand même même si on
sort des relations de prison l'autre
fois même si on sort des relations
maintenant qui prend juste à vie
professionnelle
enfin aller genre là c'est vraiment une
gobain en deux semaines mais après ça ça
va être plus beau look l'après seule
elle c'est vraiment un clip la pression
du court tout le temps après ta culture
tend ainsi de rattraper quelque chose le
prix ça ça arrive jamais ça arrive
jamais faut se mettre en tête arrive
jamais secours après quelque chose de
dépendances tu apprécies paul le jouer
je retiens lol oui ben brik et le vide
quand atteint l'objectif que tu t'es
atteint c'est parce qu'on repart les
athlètes après big tu te rends compte
qu'ils aient finalement tu te sens vide
puis malheureux parce que quand tu vois
mal parce que ça va mal se des problèmes
d'argent ça va mal à jobs se remet avec
tableau de marche malheureux mais voici
pourquoi
mais quand quand arrive au bout le ça va
bien dans ta carrière est atteint son
objectif de finir mes tontons contre ou
que jenson chapeau pipi luttait encore
pour bien d'aider son pays selon hp dit
je peux bien encore d'un match par
secteur sur je pense hs mais le tapis de
réponse pour faire comme un toit c'est
en trouver d'autres
oui c'est juste qu'elle avait fait
creuser plus profond que cesse commencé
peut-être que non mais george forrest en
superficie puis c'est quand même vente
et d'autre des raisons ab oui s'ils sont
soit renoncer si abbas d'aller intérieur
m'a demandé c'est profondément pourquoi
je suis pas heureux maintenant oui tu
vois c'est de trouver en superficie des
trucs qui sont qui sont des réponses en
écriture la quête du bonheur maquette
moment c'est pour ça que j'en faire un
super lien vers ma série bizarre parce
que j'écris une série sur l'après vie
des athlètes olympiques puis sujet qui
est très cher aussi
bah oui oui j'écoute et comme julie
filles savent pas ce qu'ils au mondial
ce qui s'en vient parce que moi j'ai
zéro sportive le g20 parcours sportif le
gie peu son parcours artistique
intellectuel puis je comprends rien
c'était comme quelque chose que je
comprenais pas du tout puis
je travaillais sur un projet puis là je
parlais de marianne st gelais qui quand
le prit sa retraite était très émotive
en entrevue gast et mes pleurs dans une
entrevue puis en parlant des producteurs
j'ai fait mais ça doit être incroyable à
stage le de faire table rase qui m'ont
tout mettre mes projets sont toujours
quelqu'un qui fait table rase et 25 fois
dans ma vie pseudo mabi tp je répète la
même histoire over and over mais elle a
28 ans à le botte diplôme parler son job
à l'epu carrière puis leur avocat
recommence à zéro puis le son est suivi
deux ans de recherches pour écrire ça
parce que justement je connaissais pas
assez ceux que j'ai rencontrés des
athlètes puis des athlètes des
neuropsychologues les psychologues même
un seul d'un moment donné qui fait quand
même des qui qui qui qui qui est un
espèce de 15 h 20 un peu seul quand des
champions mais ça peut être beau comme
ce métier qui rencontrent des athlètes
en retrait depuis un an bouleversement
pile j'ai comme tout compris votre
espèce de construction je me suis mais
faut vraiment parler parce que ça peut
pas continuer comme ça un modèle j'ai
rencontré tellement d'athlètes que
j'avais l'impression de vivre le jour de
la marmotte y vivent
vous vivez en fait je voudrais inclure
là dedans tout la même des constructions
qui pis est tout la même espèce de
petite phase dépressive toute la carte
identitaire mais c'est toute une quête
identitaire qui vous est posée faire
dans votre adolescence puis dans votre
vingtaine puis vous êtes supposé d'avoir
comme l'expérience avec social sur le
marché du travail puis vous avez rien de
ceux en même temps c'est vous pouvez pas
voir ceci vous voulez vous rendre à
votre bus fonctionnant déterminisme il
faut que tu fasses fi de toute la
réalité points pour arriver à laure
pitti m'a rien à dire mais laisse mon cv
j'ai trois médailles olympiques puis
date que je fasse élections puis tu te
rends compte que finalement dans le ca -
2 pour au web aux bains du monde que
tout pensé tout mais parce je pense mais
c'est ce qui est contradictoire en plus
parce que tu as en face à leurs potes
pour être le meilleur
ap londres quelque chose d'aller dans un
autre milieu qui dans ce milieu pour les
gens qui ont permis le salat aucune
importance respective
c'est très très très éphémère mais je
pense que les gens d'un milliard cinq ou
six levées
mais ils peuvent pratiquer leur métier
toute leur vie et qu'ils peuvent
toujours pas comme nos jours déjà faire
une p ce théâtre là je vais écrire un
livre moi mais des fois mon site c'est
quand j'ai commencé à écrire ce sont en
congé de maternité jeter comme je suis
plus rien n'est comme un christ dans le
fond non je pense que tu es qui suis je
sais je n'écris pas ses suppôts sourçage
pâtes et les ch'tis qui suis-je ping
mais en même temps je les veux te
retrouver parce que je me suis mis
retard travail mais il ya vraiment
technique un peu plus à moi je suis en
natation où je fais du ski alpin ou des
challenges qui s'avoue lui fini
entièrement puis c'est très vous êtes
très bon barre des 17 jours la main en
fait c'est toujours la même je me
rappelle que je comprends c'est sûr pas
le cas cela mais je me rappelle que ma
dernière compétition le lendemain de ma
dernière compétition
je me demandais qu'est suède envie
j'avais pas répondre puis la veille je
te dis je te mangerais le lendemain la
seconde que c'était terminé
la seconde qui s'est terminée trois
questions en vie si je n'ai rien à
répondre une perte de sens complet c'est
toute ta vie était dessiné par un
objectif qui justement comme suit pas le
temps trop trop s'écarter cet objectif
là parce que c'est la chose principale
c'est la seule chose qui doit exister si
tu veux ouais performer puis non
seulement c'est la perte de ce sens le
roman chose de plus dur mais la perte de
ta gang d'amis la perte de tout un
réseau de monde qui supporte de un
sentiment d'appartenance
oui oui c'est ça que je trouvais qu'ils
étaient pas ce que ton frère parle ici
d'un event qui voulait dans son film
montrer le côté social l'espèce des
normands ont noté une équipe de sport
on a tous un besoin de d'un groupe
d'appartenance - d'appartenance à quoi
que ce soit vous êtes ensemble longtemps
et puis donc leur cancer quand ça
s'arrête même si tu dis on continue de
voir y ait pas de nouveaux continuent de
voir les autres hi-fi continue d'être
dans un espèce de rue pour continuer la
production met pas dehors entreprendre
avec qui ça isole lui même les femmes de
joueurs dans qu'avis quand même arrêter
joaquin terminer mon cercle d'amis
je n'ai pu éviter pourtant il ya 11 ans
prouve que j'ai joué au hockey pour
bourhane
faire des levées de fonds s comme 91 pu
cesser pu tpu la faculté complètement
isolée plus de monde pourquoi j'ai
pourquoi j'ai fait tout ça mais il ya
comme donc quelque chose faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose pour que les
athlètes puissent avoir des vies plus
équilibré sans que ça change les
résultats ce qui va être forte hausse
parce que la solution c'est le savez
peut-être que tu as plus que tu as plus
avoir le sentiment d'accomplissement
après mais c'est un meilleur
accompagnement oui oui un meilleur
accompagnement après un petit tu te
donnes et tu parlais du gars de l'armée
mercredi qu'avec des athlètes mais parce
que la ressemblance est quand même
proche de huy un vétéran qui revient que
l'oeil et un peu laissé à lui-même
depuis police le sait comme elle le
traumatiser puis là je peux pas vraiment
revenir dans société et puis il faut que
je veux remplir des sacs à l'épicerie
biche justice et j'entends un boum puis
je me collais sa tartine oui je suis
laissée à moi-même dans le fond ma
famille a peut-être une pension meeddat
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
produits montre que me reparler de ce
que fut celle avec la natation en
général il ya beaucoup de problèmes de
où l'argent va
premièrement la première chose c'est que
l'argent va beaucoup trop chez les
jeunes jeunes jeunes jeunes pour pour
booster les la jeunesse plus la relève
que le ce qui à 21 ans réussissent pas
être aux olympiques mais là on les
laisse tomber puis le rôti dit pagaye
comme ils peuvent fait qu'après si ça
fait que quand tu finissais mettons
mariano moins qu'elle est finie avait
quand même accumulé de l'argent qui lui
permettait d'exister parce que moi quand
j'ai fini je t'ai d'un dettes d'études
par de chatoï parce que j'ai pas
travailler tant que sur pour pas pour me
concentrer fait que je dépensais sa
marge de crédit pour incapable d'aller
aux cadres et aux compétitions je n'ai
pas identifié par soi-même canada
affective
il ya déjà tout sera précieux pour le
camp ça finit tôt qu'un accompagnement
si comme moi j'ai fait je me rappelle
j'ai une photo de ceux du montcel
j'avais fait le record du québec au 50 m
dos à ma dernière compétition je
recherche
j'ai reçu un chèque de 33 dollars de la
fédération de natation du québec
c'était après le sujet mais
félicitations record québécois plonger
le chèque
j'ai pris une photo avec ce qui se fait
je trouvais ça trop ridicule ces genres
lifetime de date
martin le jure le maire d'un éleveur de
l'histoire du québec dans cette
discipline aux jeux seuls 33 d'europe le
jouet des chèques de 4000 pièces par
année qui a les dents des enfants dans
des enfants dans mes enfants vers 15h
plus moche le même
même quand tu finis puisqu'elle
admettons même site unis en pleine
gloire que les gens te donne beaucoup
beaucoup d'importance que quand il est
applaudi lorsque québec y en a toujours
une plus jeune on est plus jeune qui a
dit qu'ils ramassent toute cette
attention là parce que ça exactement ce
que tu disais tantôt le ca pourrais pas
être plus vrai le quantité pour
n'importe qui à l'extérieur de ce milieu
là derrière nous émettons mettons
l'exemple de yannick lupien qui équipe
qui est un gars qu'on met d'ailleurs non
seulement médaille olympique mais comme
quand il y avait 17 ans des records du
records canadiens groupe d'âge c'est le
premier canadien à vendanger sur 50 aux
hausses encore une légende le répit dans
les alpes et qui était la figure de
natation canada pendant tellement
longtemps
la seconde où est-ce que ça s'est fini
qui se retrouve un grand gosse et quatre
tickets qui va à l'école de pompiers
avec des kids mac dès qu'il l'a
littéralement qui sont là qu'ils voient
c'est comme tchèque le guide 33 ou 34
qui est là à côté de moi c'est qui ce
que le 6 il est mêlé mais le le lui y
est là dans sa vie puis c'est comme qui
les jettent est une légende dans ce que
je faisais puis si le monde me trouve un
peu un peu retardé des trente trois ans
à l'école
ah oui si vraiment c'est clair je
suppose de irujo a emporté comme mais
voyant et pignans merde je sais pas si
concernant meilleurs podcasts audio le
saint geoirs d'acquis mais qui a joué
juste dix minutes en ligue nationale
c'est vrai ça son contrat se termine et
il est retourné chez eux puis 6 mai
travaille dans un club mythique comme le
genre votre des gens qui me
reconnaissent et pire ils vendaient les
piscines vides et comme mais jeudi
et comme pour sauver la face baptiste
parce que j'aimerais ouvrir ma franchise
inclus piscine fait que j'ai c'est que
de commencer à bord d'apprendre que j
étais comme s'inventer une histoire
parce qu'il y avait tellement honte
comme ça c'est pas que j'ai joué pour
ces enjeux enclos 608 un sentiment de
honte de retourner le fait quelque chose
qui n'a rien à me disais on sait on
s'occupait de ce que je mange ennemis
mes valises même page fallait pas que je
pense arié d'arriver à l'aéroport et des
gens qui t'attend tu es comme ça comme
un statut de comme un entourage qui
s'occupe de toi qui es tu arrives du
jour au lendemain tu es comme si j'étais
dans un bon j'aime beaucoup comment des
si j'avais pas comment et quoi tu veux
ma carte des crédits pourquoi ai-je
entropie jeter comme inquiéter vraiment
c'est ça infantilise beaucoup oui
vraiment bien mais qui sait si des fois
tu sais tu racontes des athlètes de 25
30 ans c'est comme s'ils ont une
maturité à huy ou des fois ce qu'il y
ait comme des expériences de vie et non
pas eu lieu
mais c'est aussi ça se transpose dans
plein de choses factuelles être humain
est peut-être pas fait pour tout miser
sur un aspect parce que j'ai un ami qui
avait 10 en médecine puis des
urgentologues bière des potes me dire
c'était quand on est bébé quand on sort
ça y est on y fait rien doweik
émotivement avec les filles on doute
devenu une ivg dans ce match entre nous
parce qu'on y est on est comme des
adolescents puis on n'y pensait pas une
grande maturité motive ça faisait rire
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas off tu pour
est urgentologue le mettons un sarrau le
sait juste déguerpis des infections
urinaires ça me faisait tellement ri
puis tu t'es comme on est tellement
d'admiration pour tout ce travail le
pichet comme sait les médecins vous êtes
comme au top du top lui des carences
pour on est un peu émotive mans leur fou
comme on a quand même quelque chose à
rattraper
si c'est comme parce qu'ils ont ce faux
tout que tu mises sur ta réussite mais
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup touché dans la
cadre des athlètes c'est l'espèce de
commandes sur touche après ceux à la
reconnaissance à la dopamine
j'y arriverais jamais parce qu'ils se
font que te faut que ce soit correcte
seul wyss et puis je donne un feeling
mais je m'ennuie encore l'étude
la veille une compétition même la
journée monté sur le blog pitt et
saharien qui vaut rien mais je pense
qu'il y en a qui essaient de leur créer
aussi non comme un tube in dépression
parce que tu fais comme je comprends
pourquoi je me lève le matin pour aller
faire ceci et pas de médaille au bout et
pas de médaille et pas de victoire de la
vie c'est pas être excellent médias
creuser juste comme de continuer faut
que je trouve ça beau et puis faut que
tu as envie d'expérimenter des choses
c'est ça qui fout achètent pas une
question de poser parce que c'est comme
quand tu es tu allé à od c'est comme
faire ça ressemble exactement à toutes
les parcours que j'ai vu parce que les
athlètes qui finissent vont souvent les
dans les médias parce que ya de la
lumière il ya de la reconnaissance et
comme quelque chose qui fait fi c'est
comme encadré je me disais je t'écoute
est paré en disant mais si je venais de
finir jeter comme maman et ma carrière
sportive était finie je finissais ma
maîtrise pilotes choisis comme le voyage
laventure mais dans un contexte d' a
commandé dans un contexte encadré puis
avec un but au bout puis d'accord aux
mondiaux je sais même pas si le vu aussi
le ressenti cette façon le mais c'était
comme cohérent mariage un peu la même
chose était comme je veux devenir comme
chroniqueuse sportive comme ça je vais
comme encadré puis je vais avoir comme
une reconnaissance au bout des quais
comme je l'entends salue comme ce nom
non mais bien plus mais c'est comme
cohérent car même s'ils pouvaient survie
qu'à l'intervention sur place au moment
où est-ce que où est-ce que moi chez
talea y avait pas vraiment le potentiel
de carrière médiatique après mais dans
les cantines entrées la première année à
bâle yb qui a connaissance de tout le
monde était sur le cul de caisse qui se
passait avec mettons nos plateformes
c'était vraiment plus dans l'objectif de
jusqu'à que ça me serve de premier
différence entre faire comme je veux
aller à rodez ben ali puis je vous
prends mon sac à dos que joue à la dali
well as la seule différence c'est qu'eux
j'avais 20 ans et met le pied à ceux
d'études en partage que je peux pas
payer que moi comme moi je travaillais
mais pas tant que ça puis je tenais de
ses marges le tiff et quand je suis
sorti de là c'est pas comme si j'avais
un genre de 50000 à fermer pendant ces
deux années passées soit tu vois au daeu
soit rapidement va charlevoix charlebois
mais oui ou bien dans le prochain dans
le prochain deux semaines en revenant de
ma dernière compétition dans le prochain
deux semaines je je trouve un emploi
oui bah oui parce que j'avais tué s'il y
avait rien d'autre
mais ça aussi c'est pas une question tu
sais quoi l'emploi tu trouves tu
maîtrises et altera tueur mais
j'aimerais qu'on j'aimerais ça me parle
d'enfants je suis venu vous a été remis
je vous souhaite une part parce que moi
j'écris dans la victime c'est comme ces
importants petites impulsions
c'est presque une vocation mais dans des
faux jeton entend parler d'eux quand
étudier là dedans puis dans dans ce que
tu devais faire pour ta maîtrise puis à
8 avait dit un mois après dans le fond
je me serais mis à travailler en
rédaction puis j'aurai intérêts du gd je
sais pas trop quoi peut-être en pub mais
t'avais pas de vent pas de rêves
d'auteur devait pas comme une espèce de
pulsion un jour écrire ce où c'était
plus c'est parce que tu aimais beaucoup
plus la littérature de façon comme comme
lecteur ou comme plus pour l'analyser
mais tu étais pas capable de transposer
comme écrivain ou auteur au crir jeu
n'importe quoi des films ni grenier
cadet de la littérature des romains
statut plus c'est ce qui te manque et la
passion que tu avais mettons pour la
natation mais qu'il n'avait pas de temps
pour ce ou d'essayer d'intellectualiser
en faisant un usage mais comme je pense
grand que tous les écrivains que
j'étudie fait je veux faire quelque
chose de plus basique définitivement
dans un peu de tout ouais parce que tu
milites et que ça parce que moi j'ai
toujours aimé
évidemment que des fois je me suis vu
dans le sud de la france à écrire sur
une machine à taper en me disant moi je
dois être le port louis
mais ça n'a pas duré très longtemps
j'avais quand des fois sa création le
tramway puis j'écrivais pour moi mes
sujets comme arrêté jarrett a amené je
vois pourquoi
mais après si c'est devenu vraiment un
peu secondaire puis qu'est la réalité
c'est que si je faisais pas de natation
de compétition dans le rouge et or
oui j'aurais arrêté au bac ok c'est
parce que là ça me prenait deux années
supplémentaires pour pouvoir fermer cinq
ans universitaire dans le rouge et or
comme je voulais attirer ma carrière le
plus faciles manqués puis la façon dont
jean rougeau fouette à l'université wits
fait que je fais pas la mine triste fait
j'aurais tendance est au bac le plat que
j'aurais fait autre chose mais j'ai
jamais utilisé les grands à l'époque jeu
par keita mais de façon principale
c'était nord giteau literie l'altération
c'était une passion mais c'était sec et
quel programme que je prends universités
pour notre programme je prends quel
programme je me ferais pas chier parce
que je savais que j'allais me faire
chier tous les six ans note le j'ai
rapidement su que je voulais poster ou
secondaires chez - les postes restants
rendre au cégep g t or et les pirates
eurent je trouvais sur les points qui
pèsent sur l'étude
en fait je tripais sûrement sur la
connaissance générale que ça me procure
est enneigée monsieur seraient tentés et
à mesure entrant à l'université le t on
avait un adversaire va y avait ce qu'il
appelait le programme individuel de
lecture avec les deux premières sessions
tu lisais disent être humain dans
chacune des sessions de sept livres des
romans de sept livres dans chacune des
sessions plus toutes les lire et à faire
lire dans les autres sessions aussi avec
leurs rapidement j'ai fait créé
cellphone ce type peut que je peux
apprendre je peux lire j'aime ce qui
évitera sur le terrain parce que là
j'écrivais plus après ça je me suis
intéressé au journalisme narratif
vaisseau depuis
puis j'ai aimé ce team et mamys a
toujours été clair je me levais pour
aller nager en fait mais qui devrait
être entouré de gens qui étaient comme
gr d'être un auteur sera torride ego de
moi me lit
ça va être bon il y en avait avec tout
le monde mais évidemment c'est le fameux
cliché des gens qui rentrent en
littérature parce que parce qu'ils ont
lu twilight qui ont déjà eu deux livres
des cris qui n'ont pas été publiés
c'était un désir de l'es6 était en train
d'écrire mon troisième tome de ses deux
premiers tombent son jeu un manuscrit
chez eux les anciens pilotes ce fait
comme aurait bien tant mieux si c'est
une passion pour toi puis retrouve de
quoi parce que personne d'autre va y
retrouver rien ouais mais c'est ça qui
est beau parce que toi ya tellement de
gens qui écrivent des livres qu'ils ne
lisent pas et qui leur mentait tu vas
lire ce qu'ils ont fait dix ans mon dieu
ça a été fait mille fois c'est dans la
littérature 6,3 à faire serait tout
compris mais aussi être capable d'avoir
un regard puis amusé que c'est pas
vraiment la même chose
damman d'avoir un genre de regard de
nous émettons quand je lisais mes
affaires oui puisqu'elle apprécia
mettons à côté je lisais des ddt des
textes thérèse thomson par exemple le
cash et à la maîtrise le pire que ce je
les ai mis truc c'est mitigé je peux
c'est quand même bon ce que je fais mais
il ya quand même si quelqu'un lui donne
là tu donne le choix la volée à nîmes
orléans chris thompson et je ferais la
même chose des fêtes lot dit est ce que
ça vaut vraiment la peine
est ce que je fais parce que moi se
mettront est-ce que moi ça me procure le
bien être assez pour que ça vaille la
peine de m'asseoir devant mont doré
xi'an de granby par une pulsion de
choses absolument mais tant que c'était
pendant 1 kg 80 aussi l'autre affaire
par rapport aux athlètes psychique
pascal il y avait un peu parce qu'elle
le frère de l'homme qui n'a d'yeux
reflets je sais qu'ils vivaient un petit
peu la même chose ou est ce que moi je
me disais aussi j'ai tellement pas vécu
d'affaires cause la natation c'est beau
que je me demande vraiment qui est ce
que je peux amener au monde tient avec
un thé avec mon or ces niches qu'on
pressent que je peux amener au monde
avec mon art si la seule chose que je
sais et nous remettons je pourrais
parler natation pendant
sentant sa meute amepi 5 ben entendant
malienne
cette année puis permettant intéressant
quand on a quelque chose à dire oui
qu'une fois que je parle pas du tout à
ce moment là dans le fond j'ai vécu pas
mal plus maintenant que dans les trois
dernières années sûrement que l'armée
les 20 années à vendre mais mais je
n'avais rien nature et rusty fait que
commencer à faire semblant que j'ai
quelque chose de beau non faut que sa
place à jean pascal il de tourny ce
handicap le rend possible un film jack
et les mêmes thèmes un peu que kettani
wiki sur la tête qui termine lui le
véhicule lui et passe à travers ce qui
capable de parler de tout envoyer vécu
j'ai fait un autre film sur des ados
type d'amour impossible de ses mains
étaient mondiaux on doit séparer nana
qui se gavent et cusset aussi capable
d'en parler mais c'est ça mais c'est ça
l'art en fait il faut pas forcer ce site
vécu une situation qui n'inquiète pas
envie temps de le transposer dans
quelque chose d'artistique pour le faire
comprendre ce qu'est juste que tu le
camp toit puis tu peux en parler avec
des gens in si pixar est assez pour tout
avouer plein à face auquel j'ai pas
envie d'écrire qui me passionne mais que
j'ai pas envie de partager mettons
frappe de celui de de son hub de comment
il vit a eu comme une pulsion de le
partager
ile de france c'est ça ma réalité je
voulais compreniez mais on veut le faire
pour engendrer de l'amp est citée moi
quand j'écris virage était pour
contingent de l'empathie pour les
athlètes de faire comme un c du cilss
qui vive après quand les portes ont
fermé puis qu'on les voie publique
caméra sur eux c'est épouvantable ce
qu'ils vivent on peut se parler on peut
se le voir ça a été ça mon moteur parce
que ça pouvait être mon moteur de
sportifs qui existent même si c'était
vraiment un espèce de il faut il faut
trouver une façon d'accompagner ces gens
lui trouver une façon aussi de de
comprendre les motivations peu pourquoi
on fait ça parce qu'en ce moment en
train de faire le chemin inverse
au lieu de sensibiliser les les athlètes
à il faut peut-être une vie après faut
que développe d'autres choses foucault
this book ton côté social son émotivité
ton éducation tout marché du travail
on est en train de faire en sorte que
toute la population et en une
un stress anxiété petite performance
comme tout en train devenir des petits
athlètes dans nos domaines respectifs a
essayé d'être excellent puis excellé
dans ce qu'on fait puisqu'on n'excelle
pas ben en fait le gros dos performance
puis on se fait médicamenté alors qu'on
devrait tous faire le chemin inverse se
demander pourquoi qu'on est sur terre
virginie portait la terre tourne et on
est dessus sur une planète
mais sa demande et attend c'est vraiment
la vie courte lay a quand même quelque
chose de bon dans le dépassement mal
avisée de vive voix mettons dans la
question la question qu'ont composer un
petit peu plus tôt de dire est ce qu'on
devrait être demandé aux athlètes
d'avoir une vie plus balancée ils se
rendront pas les noirs mettons le cas
j'aurais dû mon lit de mort les gens me
rappeler de quelques efforts que j'ai
vinaigre mais une des affaires que j'ai
vécu c'est les olympiques de 2008
à écouter michael phelps si piètre de
bouche monde u20 qui a trouvé convient
d'attendre le modem a rappelé toujours
tous les autres aujourd'hui grandes
baigneuses maculaire cave même parce que
je t'ai chez joe joe webb demain ils ont
checké des vidéos sur youtube j'ai dit
elle
je vais vous montrer le genre le25 rôle
de michael phelps en 2000 où tout le
monde se montrait des vidéos genre ultra
précis effectué en mars
si j'ai ralenti le milieu du guet devant
une espèce de tableau avec des ballons
qui essayait d'expliquer pourquoi ce que
je regardais de la chose la plus une
scène que j'ai vu de ma vie sept courses
le 200 kroll en 2002 michael phelps
c'est à mon avis la perfection donc
c'est la perfection c'est jamais arrivé
une épreuve comme ça je pense que même
ses mona lisa money money c'est ça mais
le problème c'est que même s'ils
accomplissent un pic c'est la mona lisa
de la natation de succès le documentaire
de william golding trice
oui mais c'est là la question la forge
ouais c'est là la question qu'il faut se
poser puis en tant qu'humanité aussi
jusqu'où on va au détriment de quoi
puis la réponse pour cette ultime pointe
le
peut-être que ça vaut la peine à wissous
mais peut-être que sa marque dans
l'histoire c'est peut-être que tout ce
qui va qui a vécu après tout la maison
elle vaut la peine pour lui après un
métier puis après ça tu penses
maintenant c est ce que ça vaut la peine
peugeot ailleurs le mais ce que ça vaut
la peine que bodoira et véhicules
menaient une vie misérable qui marque
les ors et jean sébastien bach âprement
pas une vie qui dit non mais oui mais tu
vois on ne sait comme le contraire pour
les artistes
on s'en fout quand son malheureux quand
ils ont des troubles mentaux puis qu'ils
sont des ponts des dépressions parce que
on pense que ça nourrit leur art peace
alors ça leur est haut comme un espèce
de road mystère autour d'eux parce
qu'ils soient que c'était des ermites
peas et des fois tu fais comme tout est
juste des mauvaises personnes aussi
piété vraiment pas gentils avec leur
entourage
puis au nom de leur art ont leur tout
permis je pense que je pense que tu mets
ton dédé fortin c c'est sûr que paix
dans le monde se sont dit on laisse
aller parce que c'est un artiste un
chanteur c'est correct sont des
pressions pcci qui s'enferme dans un
chalet pour écrire dehors novembre
mais peut-être que si on l'avait aidé il
serait encore ici aujourd'hui a écrit la
musique c'est aussi on n'avait pas pris
a été réécrit d'or bat van bay peut-être
oui mais si c'est oui parce que il
aurait pu l'écrire épée dans une phase
difficile mais si on avait pu les
départs comme tu es en train de dépérir
montgueux l'outil est quelque chose que
les gens qui ont des troubles mentaux
dans la vie qui fusion des forces de la
santé mentale ça se traite
faut pas se dire oh mais ces gens le
savent roms et leur leur créativité au
pire ils vont la retrouver autrement pu
mieux que ces jeux pensés comme c'est
comme comparer les relations toxiques
phares comme à c'est aider au dépit des
baumes on part en voyage présents on se
laisse à marseille qu'un des fleurs mais
c'est comme ça pour être plus tabou c
est tout aussi beau mais pour les
athlètes je pense que c'est peut-être de
garder ce déterminisme l'homme est vous
rentrez dans fait ta valeur n'est pas
que d'être un champion qui sait sur la
folle mais ça fait peu de toi un
surhumain par rapport aux autres
c'est cette époque n'a pas plus de
valeur parce que moi ce que je trouve un
ratio gratification c'est ça la france
parce que
ces gens là leur seul gratification
c'est dans le succès c'est la raison
pour laquelle à chaque matin ils veulent
aller rechercher ceux qui sont allés
sacrifie tout le reste de l'argent parce
que la vie ce possible pour ça mais
c'est sûr qu'on pourrait peut-être
trouvé une façon si je parlais avec le
préparateur mental de marianne pied des
collines parlem par led comme acquis
qu'ils avaient été capables à guider
tout au long de son parcours olympique
puis comment qu'ils pouvaient faire des
forces du deuil à un temps rap et depuis
c'est comment puis après quand j'ai dit
mais pourquoi après ça déraille et puis
l'un me dit mais c est le vécu une
rupture a le plus gagné au jeu et eu du
true blood avec jeu mais il y avait
comme trop gros trop main j'ai fait mais
qu'est ce que tu fais avec ce vide et
comme je sais pas mouche pop si je
préparateur mental
il y avait donc une vie maladie avec
toute l'humilité seconde est trop moche
avec cette impression que le j'obtiens
des olympiques prends ta carrière
je pense pourtant eu d'accompagnement
qui te suivent encore fax et sinon il
aurait quelque chose à faire c'est
jusque là le futur des olympiques c'est
qu'il y ait des chinois qui ont trois
ans puis qui s'entraîne pour aller aux
olympiques dans 20 ans et qu'on peut pas
dire aux gens non à une vie plus
équilibrée ici vie sort des fois puis
fait une maîtrise en même temps pour
avoir une vie plus équilibrée parce que
tu es contre des robots six ans
maintenant et je ne sais pas où l'être
humain doit aussi des gens qui sont les
métis et on le sait déjà a loué le
savoir est arrivé d des gens qui ont
mettons y prennent d'eux et ce tigre à
chinois ils font à la boucle c'est enfin
le nez à et mesure celle des caps qui a
pas de peine
enfin voila vous même et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut se ramener à la passion parce
que des passions tu peux faire toute ta
vie c'est qu'ils font aussi parce que
c'est sûr jamais rien géré beaucoup tu
peux pas juste continue patiner ses
thèmes sont comme tout passionné
oui c'est ça mais toi quand tu parles
avec jérémy demay que vous obteniez ce
la musique vieille de l'euro dollar à
tarnos
mais tout s'est mis à parler de la
fréquence musicale c'était tellement
beau jeu comme un métier c'est ça être
passionné de quelque chose peut donner
un sens à ce qu'on fait pippo par
l'ésotérisme par la science faire comme
s c'est mathématique aussi la musique je
sors c'est en effet vers table en fait
j'ai essayé de trouver une manade d'être
en accord avec ce qu'ils disent est dans
ce sens qu il a les possibilités
musicales existe des jeux à bascule pour
mathématisée la musique dont la cli
combinaison se peuvent mais les
fréquences est déjà dans la nature c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on peut
nécessairement inventé sont déjà
souhaité combinaisons sont là donc il ya
quelque chose à la fois scientifique
puis mathématiques pierre même temps je
sentais que ça te faisait vibrer piste
est intéressante et même moi ça
m'intéressait ouais je verse tic et
esther un peu cela leur théorie que la
musique est bon les ventes pourront
l'année ouvre on la découvre mais se
mettre soi c'est pour ça qu'on peut
s'émerveiller de la vie je veux vraiment
voir leur bain et de kelly l'ours mais
c'est pour ça qu'on pousse et
s'émerveiller de la vie pu trouver du
sens dans la vie peut trouver ça beau
quand en parlant de choses super
rationnelle puis tout par terre à terre
sans rentrer dans bono qui se fait
envoyer des chansons par dieu c'est là
que des fois le l'afo spiritualité vient
de choquer comme la vie et la vie c'est
déjà assez beau il y avait vraiment de
la merde partout en même temps mais est
déjà quelque chose d'assez beau dans le
concret oui mais ses mots c'est
merveilleux ce qu'espère beau non je me
suis complètement 3 713 bouge ton
artiste mais j'ai vraiment intéressés
par la science puis par l'astrophysique
ce qui y est tellement déjà de beauté
dans le monde des visites dans les
choses matérielles dans le cosmos de
dans l'humain comme un conte effet dans
l'infiniment petit et y est tellement de
choses complètement muet incroyable et
éthique qui sont quesemand de qu'on
pourrait attribuer à la mer
j mais qu'en réalité c'est explicable
sexuellement mais c'est beau pareil mais
en tout cas il y avait un site web n'en
peut plus et qui me déçoit un site web
qui existe ou est ce que tout les livres
qui ont été écrits et qui vont être
écrit existe ah ouais j'en ai fait un
nom mais ces gens tu peux toutes les
combinaisons possibles jumeaux sont dans
ce sens au sénat
c'est vrai que j'ai un peu tout les
livres qui vont être écrit existe oui
parce qu'elle est y avoir des trucs
d'intelligence artificielle pour écrire
des romans qui vont comme signé un nom
d'autres où ça me fait capoter mais
c'est vrai mais mathématiquement il ya
un nombre limité de mots doux dans les
combinaisons limite d'un mode en cui
donc c'est tout mais séries existent
déjà
mon film qui paye 10 lits j'ai déjà
écrit fameux ça me rassure énormément
dans un big ben est aussi formidable ça
m'agace au départ ça j'espère juste
qu'ils viennent écrit liban mais c'est
vrai quand on pense à ce mets ça enlève
seuil et déjà que vos cookies pourrait
trouver sa terre à terre puis un peu
plat puis justement sans magie et moi je
consomme magique je trouve ça beau tu
sais je suis blessé c'est de le
découvrir
william evans mais prof à l'université
qui disait que la littérature soit comme
l'archéologie dont on histoires existent
faut juste que tel je trouve ça vraiment
l'écrivain tu dois tout et c'est vrai
qu'on finit toujours par écrit la même
affaire avec terme des mots différents
et comme toujours en affaires rien de
nouveau sous le soleil y arrimer le seul
à aimer les gens égocentré qui dirait
c'est tout a été dit mais pas par moi
c'est ça je me dis à chaque fois je
parle beau projet a déjà été fait mais
pas par moi militer va falloir qu'on
mais je veux avant parce que je sais que
c'est comme ça que cissé india qui nous
a écrit pied pour eux pour parler du
fait que tu voulais venir nous pas fait
les choses
non mais là nous sommes manipulés
lorsqu'atteint comme je veux vraiment y
ait ce flou voire je veux leur parler
si le chèque en main mais non mais sa
pote bourse à plat le fait non qui me
veut y aller mais allez créer une espèce
de situation où je suis ici ou là exact
la raison pour laquelle initialement a
dit allez qui aiment la somme de vous
parler d'eux qu'ils payent la première
règle cgc pour un fait ça c'est un sujet
qui était chaud qui a été qui a amené à
beaucoup de débats qu'on en reparle et
après ça manquait une théorie qui dit
que oui ah oui bref pourquoi tu voulais
nous partageons pas ce que parce
qu'encore à ce jour le jury paraître à
la fin c'est que le petit des choses qui
me tue regrets beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui je me suis oui je suis
emporté j'en ai parlé à usage pourrait
peut-être mettre mes messages beaucoup d
les piles à tout acheter comme à oui
c'est pour ça que je suis une en france
que chez l'homme non mais je vais aller
le dire je valide je veux le rencontrer
je voyais écrit péter comme no no no pis
j'avais un propos très tranchées tout
était lecture et alizée lochte est prête
à faire tout le monde est beau mais là
il me parlait pas mais comme toute
nuance et mon affaire je comprends son
poème je comprends ton point et même si
on n'est même pas encore débat dessus
mais c'est quoi que je dise banques sous
les parodies que moi je suis allé
prendre des cafés toi il faut comparer
quelque chose après après je m'en veux
idéalise le monde la porte puis toi tu
veux juste parler car à côté des bacs à
sable
je pense que je te sérieux oui je pense
que tu dis pas tu as peut-être que tout
oui je te prie mieux au brome de grue
mais je me suis dit c'est injuste mais
dont les dix premiers prenez prenez pas
tout ce qu'on dit inquiète le premier
venu mais mes qualités je pense c'est un
hôpital rien d'en parler pour que ce
soit ramenée sur terre
je vais faire faute de brut perd ça va
aller plus vite que payer au restaurant
mais je pense que tu mélanges qui est
dans la vie quand on dit c'est que ça
doit être le fun sans doute avec une
belle fille sadr est dense des
circonstances le funky en privé pics
mélange pas avec ce jeu peut être payé
pour ce petit vous avec des super belle
fille avec qui tu connecte avec kitten
chimie pis que c'était super bien payé
pour ça alors que les conditions c'est
beau ce moyen c'est peut-être des faits
ce serait comme un habile mais chris
hadfield peau il ya un goût kg genre qui
te regardent leurs commandes
vous êtes loin qu'un chèque de 400 ans
pierre effectif je pense que tu t'es
comme fait un fantasme de la dans des
conditions la grande et belle chambre
d'hôtel piet de la musique mais c'est un
néo ici le pilat fille avait accouché
genre 8 go mais tout ce que j'ai fait en
il sait comme tout enfant d'âge la porte
il faut que je ramène sur terre non mais
ce que tu dis le jeu c'est intelligent
pour savoir sous 3d vidéo table on a
même est exactement moi c'est moi ce que
j'imaginais c'est plus un genre de truc
avec des masques et il ya des chaînes de
monde qui font juste un couple sont
total et 12 tu vois jamais leur phase
puis maintenant faire là dessus
puis il y en a ça marche très bien
d'être émoussé genre ce que j'imaginais
c'est plus une chose comme ça mais je le
sais je le ferai jamais et puis je le
sais que c'est ces semis a joke dans le
sens qui est si je suis fait des doutes
là dessus c'est parce qu'il ya un petit
quelque chose dans cette église est plus
cool be nice
mais je t'assure que le scot
exhibitionniste
oui mais parce que ça implique une
caméra puis d'une audience fait que ça
deux ni quelque chose à demain mais
c'est ce qu'aurait lors des fantasmes
qu'on n'a pas envie de réaliser un petit
peu même exactement ce que je pense que
c'est vraiment de se tordre le hacker et
pis je le sais que tu sais moi c'est
surtout parce qu'il faut que je faisais
avec thomassique si je disais également
mais pas les parents morts demain matin
l'acteur porno parce que c'est la seule
chose que la seule chose qui me retenait
d'un parent c'est le jardin familial
jugement les parents
écrit tout à fait déjà savoir qui était
quand même parce que j'aime la musique
je trouve toi je pense pas que je
tirerai ma vie que j'ai lu pour cette
vidéo je pense très bien en ce moment
puis j'ai pas besoin d'aller voir ce
pays peut-être mais non mais tu peux
l'admettre peu comme tout proche de
faire comme si vous aimez ça en dit
beaucoup c'est dans ce n'est pas le
regard de mes parents sur moi c'est
qu'est ce que je ferais pas quelque
chose enfin plus aller au lit ouais mais
tu vois mais c'est sûr mais ça va
société il ya une grosse grosse part
d'humour mais c'est parfait mais avec te
manger selon le top et sa folie si ce
sera la fin de son style si des enfants
très tranchés comme j'ai visité l'aide
pay pay the plus les feuilles et les
pays parce qu'il veut faire du reste
évasif parce que je pense pas trop à me
convaincre je le pense je pense pas aux
pressions quand on va réussir à être
convaincu après ça je vais être votre
fini par tout un peu raison mais c'est
quoi ton mais je t'ai pas parce que le
avec votre conversation de textes du
film je n'ai pas d'accord avec aucune
des chèques en main et voyons mais mais
il dira me ramener sur terre
certaines choses s'il ya un contexte
économique des fois c'est parce que je
pense que je m'imagine trop que legault
qui invite moi je pense que la prudence
parce que tu viennes sur le thunder bay
quelque chose qui s'est passé le gars
qui invite oui c'est ça et dès que je
pense que c'était que je sois faut que
ce soit difficile j'étais vite invite
quelqu'un toshiba terre en ce moment
ouais ok c'est ça la fin c'est ça la
france lorsque parce que moi j'aimerais
bien moi je n'invite pas à quai j'invite
passait en voiture au resto non pas tant
qu'elle se projetant le jeudi au
président à sa candidature en bière
devant tué et mangé ça tu penses tu de
ce pas se projeter vite parce que
j'envoie reprendre guillaume dulude
comme exemple si guillaume durand qui
est des théories il parle comme si les
hommes et les femmes montent et 50 50
socialement économiquement que le
rapport de pouvoir et l 55
mais on vit dans une société et que je
te retires qui on vit dans une société
où les hommes gagnent plus et les hommes
dépensent moins par rapport à ce qu'ils
sont si vous avez vraiment comme un coût
social à être une femme
donc amis dont tu dis cristal ou aux
restaurants payer 200 pièces prendre vie
que je suis même pas son devoir mais là
ils paient pas de choix pour s'habiller
sadok sur toi oui oui elle a le prix une
contraception qui coûte quelque chose
chaque mot est peut être allée se faire
faire les choses avaient peut-être coûté
150 pièces tout son maquillage c'est
creham ses souliers tout le coût social
de sortir de chez elle demandait de se
mettre bien parce que c'est un exemple
c'est parce que je bête avec un
cardiologue qui va x 600 mille pilotes
est là avec ces graines de haricot tech3
technique des projets étaient des
subventions à se battre didier peut-être
que dans le fond même cei a coûté plus
cher s'habiller pour la sortie fixée
jusqu'au parc éolien ce que face aux
grandes dents ce we
non je peux pas commencer c'est parce
que je trouve que l'espèce de violence
masculine en faisant je trouve que des
fois il ya des égos qui deviennent
frustrés en faisant vous voulez tout le
monde peut évidemment pas égal mais
aussi mais c'est comme il n'y a pas
d'égalité au sénégal pas ce mot puis moi
je comprends mais ont la plume mais en
général les femmes gagnent moins que les
hommes
ils font moins d'économies que les
hommes c'est du sud à faire des
économies quand tout un coût social
d'être ce que tu es puis quand tu es
moins payés ça fait en sorte que tous
moi je sais même pas mais je trouve que
je peux payer moins que les scénaristes
masculin que j'aurais jamais jack et
nous avons fait tilter mais je sais que
si j'étais un homme je serai pas
vraiment plus riches en ce moment je
dépenserai beaucoup moins sur mon
putting apparence physique
mais ceci étant dit je pense que dans
mon exemple il ya deux choses
j'ai comme deux billets lé là dedans ce
que je m'imagine tout le temps keystone
dès qu'un gobelet piges j'ai trop
rencontré godet fois qui justement sont
célibataires mais qui gagnent bien leur
vie qui ont de l'argent puis que
deviennent frustrés après 3 4 dead 2
dépenser de l'argent puis pas votre sexe
beau à voir mais quelques lacs et
sadique puis effectif quand j'entendais
goffart comme je pense que j'avais un
passé historique des amis qui font comme
elle le christ a pas d'âge pour
[ __ ] 150 pierrefonds a fait jeter comme
août où il ya des gars qui entrent dans
les relations ils paient beaucoup qui
est une espèce de violence économique
s'écrie la danse à ce que vous savez moi
tu vois ce dossier mais comme j'ai
appris que jamais c'est une des théories
auquel je peux maintenant par rapport à
ma propre situation de force à ses vrais
d'avoir amené du conte d'abord senti que
je me faisais abuser oui recule après
comme je plus jamais payé sauf que sauf
cas encore une fois pu l'admirer
économique duquel tu parles je l'entends
oui sauf que je pense trop que c'est du
cas par cas pour que sa dette pour qu'on
puisse s'en servir comme une règle
générale parce que maintenant moi-même -
si chez que vive
c'est un coup de moins chaque la fille
que je vois oui j'ai aucune idée de sa
réalité économique
je peux juste qu'on est la mienne piché
que moi 250 pièces pour un super d'une
première des c'est beaucoup d'argent
oui oui si c'est beaucoup d'argent alors
que cette personne ne la connaît pas
ouais je les pains j'ai pas dis je
t'invite le happy est dit on va au resto
à l'accepter de venir au resto avec moi
sachant les crocs en jambe mois
connaissant les coûts que cela engendre
mois le resto j'accepte d'aller d'au
moins six chars de la kabyle de 200
pièces puisque une première je sais qu
est-ce que 200 pièces ça représente dans
mon budget je sais que je peux pas faire
ce way
une fois par semaine une fois par
semaine puis que advenant la possibilité
que je refasse une belle comme ça ça
peut pas être un précédent que c'est moi
qui paye à chaque fois que moi il ya
comme ça puis attendez que c'est du cas
par cas gens dans ce que tu dis je pense
pas que ça s'applique globalement je
pense que tu peux arriver en dix ans en
dix ans c'est vrai que dans la société
défi payent plus pour moins d'argent à
vie puis ça peut-être pas d'impact
puisque il ya une fille qui t'intéresse
petit voilà ça rend con pis c'est la
meilleure façon pour tous et d'échanger
un repas en commun abord parce que c'est
ce qu'il faut c'est plus fun à voir une
dette au resto qu'au cinéma ou tu parle
peu mais par exemple des projets choisis
un resto que ça va te coûter 250 bien
cessèrent d'être pimentée moi petit
mettant des deux dernières années avant
que je raconte ma blonde d'italie 0 fois
un resto est en train d'aller se détend
des styles et genres 0 face au but est
de 150 tu vois quelque part que ton se
prend deux points chacun au genre depuis
sa clique qui est sa clique puis sa
clique poésie populaire que subissent à
nous écouter veille et bien oui c'est ça
mais c'est que ça me paraît la bonne à
une bonne avenue première de la force
parce que moi je vois pas dans debate
avec du manque du géo qu'une des 2,6 ça
va avancer jamais vraiment livré ouais
mais on est comme moi pour moi leur
couverture il a service cesser plus loin
dans la sphère joaillier de ces sommes
et c'est comme ça que il devient tout
déborde simon affaire tout est construit
mon argument parce qu'elle a dit mais si
tu privilèges et privilégient ce sont
comme un homme comme argument te donne
juste davantage à des gars qui ont de
l'argent de rencontrer des filles et des
garçons
ab oui bon c'est la charnière architecte
est juste les gars qui vont qui vont des
td qui ont les années dans l'est dans
des restaurants alors que sont peut-être
pas sûr aussi intéressant qu'un geek est
juste le moyen terme et prendre un café
je sais ce que c'est un espèce de la
hiérarchie pi 10 po en bout de ligne la
valeur de la facture salée aucune
incidence fondamentale dont il est sûr
que tu peux très approprié maman s'est
campé par la caf et le problème marche
ça peut être super cool oui oui oui mais
surtout se voir en vrai le marché les
applications sont petits et toujours de
rencontrer son obligation est justement
semble être un peu partie souvent
instagram où tout ça va servir de
premier contact puis rapidement ajoute
avec la personne écrit c'est déjà un
premier indice de comme ça l'obligé à le
tuer lui mourra le talent et l écriture
comme du monde où il est critique comme
du monde
toutefois prendre un café ou bien pour
le oui non puis je peux comprendre c'est
in them dit moi je paye toujours ma
moitié de la facture comme sautiller
comme un rapport égalitaire qui 5,5
s'installe vite et personne ne doit rien
à personne si c'est comme on parle de le
je trouve que la méthode fait beaucoup
d'argent
bien vite une fille super bourrin c'est
qu'ils mangent est féministe je
comprends mais en bout de ligne
parce qu'il n'y a pas de règle ap ce
sens que ça peut pas être une attente
non merci parce que ça fait que des gens
comme moi toujours parce la fais ça tu
as well as they come baby g sourire oui
vraiment je comprends non mais de
s'adapter à la réalité économique de
chacun je comprends seul je peux dans
l'air mais je pense quand même pas si ça
sexy c'est sûr je pense que généralement
faudrait ne pas avoir d' adaptation dans
les premières boucles
mais dans les premières dites vous
suffit juste et ce à chaque est son
affaire quand tu le sais pas la personne
c'est le pot à moins que ce soit classé
mettons si tu veux si ça dérange pas toi
de ça c'est une pièce le dire je
t'invite pays date si tu le dis
le ca vient de régler la question si le
vocabulaire oui vraiment ça demande une
demande et beaucoup de vulnérabilité
aussi pour un goût de faire comme
tchèque le chou pas d'amener les
personnes faisaient oui j'ai pas les
moyens
mais en même temps c'est que les banques
et que maintenant et on veut tous mus au
sim et on se propose de mustapha comme
un peu d'âme on dit que tu le payes
louis et on va tous mus aux pellets ses
jambes l ouest et 300 pièces toi trop
simple fait qu'il ya ça aussi c'est
gratuit si c'était les prenais un café
belle aura du lieu de la facture et
bibia de café genre de l'après mixant sa
carte la fac et ouais oui parce que même
toi tu veux pas une fille qui veut juste
aller oumou sow non mais non mais c'est
ce pistard est-ce que tu payes tout le
temps tout moi je veux pas parce que
c'est une construction sociale des fois
d'une femme ça doit être ce jeune homme
s'adresse aux messes et il ya un truc
aussi qu'il faut pas penser que l'homme
est là pour être en voyant tout petit
positionne comme une espèce de truc
c'est ça que ce qui m'agace un peu
l'autre fois dans un podcast avec les
jeunes je n'aimerais pas personne mais
l'espèce de ça s'appelle du sexisme
bienveillant c'est en faisant on et moi
j'aime ce que mange jamais facile face
aux pics qui me traite comme un principe
d'une poupée ce salaire qt à leurs books
à leurs protecteurs mais ça crie
automatiquement une relation est inégal
méthodes comme ça mais c'est parce
qu'une différence entre prendre soin
puis prendre soin de l'autre pic comme
c'est comme ton égal puis faire en sorte
que ça sente confortable et en sécurité
avec toi puis la garder comme un enfant
qu'il faut protéger puis et parigné puis
chouchouté par ce faux si tu veux avoir
une relation saine c'est que ces boues
il ya comme un chapitre complet latine
en ligue 2 les points creuse pour
l'amour des hommes d'affaires comme say
say say say say prouver que les
relations qui font qu'ils finissent mal
parce qu'il ya comme quelque chose
d'illégal par capelli site traite
tablons mais je veux faire je le met
très en très gros lot mais comme comme
cette petite fille qui a besoin d'être
protégée comme c'étaient des jeunes
victimes
elle va voir la difficulté s'épanouir a
affirmé qu'en tout
faire quelque chose par contre moi
j'aide étaient des filles qui
s'attendaient à ce que je les traite
comme ça mais bon c'est pas comme ça
parce que j'ai peur avec une relation à
soi seul et unique qui ça peut
fonctionner comprend elle à faire son
chemin en faisant cherche un père ou
chercheurs parce que je cherche
quelqu'un qui va me dominer pics et jan
poser moins de questions dans vivre
juste faire tout le monde veut que je
sois où je veux m'affirmer en tant que
femme [ __ ] mais ça demande beaucoup de
courage s'affirmer en tant que femme
dans la vie par comme les choses que je
choisir des choses que je veux je veux
pas m'imposer
parce que ça peut être facile aussi
faire comment je veux juste qu'on me
laisser guider dans la vie de l'autre
mais quand ça finit est détruit est-ce
qu'on dise c'est là sinon mes passions
comme ceux qui se trouvent les y ait
plein femmes cherchent leurs repères
piqué qui trouvent des rations vais très
enveloppante où ils sont mais par
séquences a fini le non seulement tu es
dans un chagrin d'amour mais tu es comme
un athlète dans une quête identitaire je
suis qui s'insultent et homme le jeu qui
économiquement je suis qui sur le marché
du travail mais sont l'enjeu topic
tu es dans une vide 2-2 de deux femmes
qui se fait vivre puis kiki qui est
soumise à son mari mais que dis je suis
bien et maintenant je peux être bien là
dedans mais qu'est ce qui arrive si ça
finit ce jour au lendemain tu es qui toi
sans cette personne ne faut quand même à
chacun son shopping féminisme c'est
d'assumer qui a tous les choix sont
possibles en tant que vie mais en même
temps faut comprendre le prix à payer
sur ton épanouissement d'êtres humains
venus quand tu t'offres toute sa fille
toutes tes choix entre évident annoncé
mais si c'est pas c'est pas genre est
une tête fait de la soupe le piquant des
malades puis dîner avec dans le front
qui essaie comme non parce que je pense
que non parce que je pense que les
hommes auraient vraiment intérêt à
prendre à prendre soin c'est un non
sujet le voudrez inviterez mais ça
arrive comme un truc complètement changé
ma vie puis ma vision du féminisme car
je me suis dit ok le féminisme c'est pô
juste les femmes qui deviennent des
hommes mais c'est aussi les hommes qui
qui apprennent dès que ça s'appelle
l'héritage féminin les émotions féminine
s'est poliment les masters féminins
c'est pas mon dieu pleuré en regardant
mes
mais c'est prendre soin prendre soin des
enfants être capable de transposer ses
besoins puis de prendre soin de ceux
qu'on aime être à l'écouté de faire
passer les autres avant soi qui pour se
sacrifiait pour parce que pour son
propre bonheur
en bout de ligne c'est de trouver c'est
juste de trouver la manière de vivre
loin il convient dans lequel on est à
différents pour chacun c'est dur de dire
avec les gens qui font ça peut monter à
qui nous confions chamakh et vous ce qui
ne convient à nous puisque vient qu'on
ce qui ne convient pas c'est différent
pour un autre point de vue ça nous
paraît comme quelque chose d'impossible
de complètement farfelu mais pour
d'autres le marché oui avec ses seules à
discuter mais je comprends aussi que des
foyers des pillages auxquels les gens
tombent oui comme moi oui c'est ça mais
pour moi qu'on est proche et démons par
la horde et on va comme analysé les
nouveaux personnages merci d'avoir
écouté ce podcast jusqu'à la fin de ce
pas que vous avez apprécié la
conversation ça prouve que vous êtes de
réelles fans de conversation et sans fil
pas de casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe bien sûr p tu es a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde piquionne ou est
ce que on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi
de la conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir
ce qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur
dans certains sujets qu'on voulait
aborder ou qu'on a abordé pendant le
podcast donc
allez sur notre page de turenne et le
lien vers savoir dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin